e
e e
what is going on with my
computer okay we'll get underway shortly
I just need to get myself organized here
God
okay good morning everybody Welcome to
environment and agriculture
committee um today we are going to um be
missing representative sofikitis and
representative um
ktoa um I don't know where if
representative Potenza will be late but
in any case um um what I would like to
have please representative Kenny lead us
in the pledge of
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the repblic for
it stands one nation under God
indivisible liberty and justice for
all so this morning morning's work um we
are have a number of bills that uh we
have slated for a discussion in a uh
full committee work session we will
um be uh engaging in this work session
till 11 o'clock then we'll take a short
break for uh caucus and then uh at 11:20
we will reconvene to uh exec some bills
out of our committee so um on our
uh list of bills to discuss this morning
uh for uh bills that are either being
were heard last week or the week before
actually welcome back Everybody by the
way
um uh we had a a a couple of bills that
were heard uh the last time we met and
then we had some other bills that were
still being worked on uh had uh various
amendments uh being worked on and um so
we're going to we're going to cover
those today uh the first bill that we
wanted to discuss this morning was HP
152 prohibiting the sale and use of
adhesive based rodent traps um who would
like to open the discussion on that this
morning represent Bixby good morning so
um one of the uh so I I uh one of the
things that um we that I I got from a I
got a u letter from a constituent who's
Point who pointed out that one of the
problems with glue traps is they just
are they're more expensive and not as
effective as snap traps and that this is
something that the general public might
not be very well aware of although uh
people who are uh professionals dealing
with uh Pest Control situations uh are
you have a better grasp of when you want
to you when you might need to use a uh
glue trap and when you uh when a snap
trap would be more effective uh so one
of the things that I um uh learned in
talking with a representative of The
Pest Control Association is that uh
their their General guidelines their
best practices uh include fairly rare
use of uh of glue traps there are two
main places where they would use them
one is if they have a repeating trap
where uh if the uh if it catches a a a
lot of mice then if there if the mice
are not immobilized inside it they tend
to cannibalize each other uh so what the
what the glue traps in that situation
would do would would be to cause them to
die sooner and not not eat each other in
the process um the uh other situation
where they would use them is if they are
uh doing a clearing out an area and they
uh where they know that they're going to
be when they open up the uh like
an area from beneath um cabinets or
beneath shelving and they know that
there are uh a lot of animal a lot of
mice hiding under there and that the
mice are just going to go running in
every direction they will do a perimeter
of glue traps in order to catch them at
which point once they're once they're
caught that way they can be disposed of
very quickly and killed humanely uh so
uh those are the two main places where
they would use glue traps that are
targeted towards rodents uh and what
this so I'm thinking that uh one thing
one way we could amend this bill would
be to
uh uh re retain the ability of people
who are doing uh professional Pest
Management to use glue traps because
they they do have a set set of
procedures where they know how to use
them but uh for someone who is just
going to a Home Depot and looking on the
shelf and saying okay do I do a SN nap
trap do I do a glue trap oh I don't know
the difference I'll just do a glue trap
uh if they're not on the Shelf at Home
Depot they'll default towards the better
option which is the snap
trap uh so I was thinking maybe an
amendment to that effect would be uh
would be a an improvement on the bill uh
and I'd be happy to see what other
people think of
that okay any
other
comments representative King
thank you madam chair um just a couple
notes I have written um that I that I
was thinking of when the um bill was
being heard publicly
um and that is that um you know snap
traps can be really brutal too we we
have a lot of mice that like to come
into the house every winter and um and
there's a lot of we kill a lot of mice
every winter and we always use the snap
traps um but you know usually what'll
happen when you you can often hear them
where where we have them placed you can
hear them and it's like a few seconds of
squiggling and then they stop squiggling
but sometimes every once in a while
it'll it'll get them in the back or
something and you hear squiggling and
you say okay they'll they'll be dead in
a few seconds 30 seconds later any
second now they'll be dead I I've heard
I've heard M mice squiggle for 15 20
minutes and it's like okay time to go
get it and you know I I've had to put it
in a paper bag and then bash it with a
shoe so um that's pretty brutal too so
the the snaps aren't aren't necessarily
more Humane and then um the other thing
is uh we experimented once with the um
the so-called Humane ones which just
safely trap them and then you're
supposed to get them and take them
outside and uh well we forgot and uh
months later we found a desiccated Mouse
in there so that's not great either and
that's our fault but I just know that um
even the Humane ones so-called Humane
ones if they're not if they're not
operated properly it's really not Humane
and the so-called inhumane ones the glue
traps if done properly I think are quite
Humane so a lot of it comes down to the
user um and I just think that whether
you're dealing with a so-called Humane
or inhumane one it's it's going to come
down to the user so if the user has
their head on straight they'll do it
right um so that's all I have to say
about that and to your point I mean you
know when you I I've been into the
stores recently to see uh how these uh
glue traps
are marketed sold whatever and it
clearly says on the packaging not to be
used in an open
space to be checked you know regularly
to make sure that uh you know you're not
leaving this rat or whatever uh to to be
there for a long time and and the plain
fact of the matter is that it all comes
down to Consumer
education
um to to representative bixby's Point um
about
um maybe not allowing these to be sold
to the public and then just have
professionals use them
then you know you're kind of forcing
people to use a professional service
when they may not have the money to do
that some of these Professional Services
are
expensive and
um I think for the most part too that
you know people people are looking for
non-chemical means to
control pests and I I
just for me I I just think that um you
you know we we need
to educate the public on how to properly
use them if they're going to use them I
mean I think we just
have to me
um
rodents are a problem they carry
diseases and if we have a non-chemical
means to control them and I know that
there are many non-chemical means to to
control them but why would we want to
remove a non-chemical means when we're
also looking at removing chemical means
I mean it it why would we want to keep
limiting our choices and I just think
that um it's it's just not something
that we can we can easily make an an
amendment that would be uh something
that would work because uh
and and to be honest I think that a lot
more people now are being educated and
are not buying these glue traps I know
personally I wouldn't buy one I wouldn't
um but there are a lot of people who
want to have that choice and I think
that uh you know the more we educate
people in the public to make sensible
choices and let the market decide
whether these things should be sold or
not if they're not if they're not
popular and they're not being sold
manufacturers won't make them
representative
Barber thank you um my stumbling block
on this was the idea that you can buy
these on the internet I know that the
bill states that they cannot be shipped
into the state but that's an Enforcement
issue that I would find very difficult
to follow through on um records would
have to be kept um so for me me that
that was the biggest issue was that we
can't actually prevent them from coming
into the state um and for people to buy
them you know and be using them so I
don't know if there's a an answer to
that um but that is a a big stumbling
block for
me representative Miner and then
representative H Haskins thank you madam
chairman I think much like uh there
isn't a kind of gentler machine gun
there isn't a kind of gentler rodent
trap um I think we I think we can put
this to bed by letting um the
professionals decide what is what is
right for them to use in these
situations it's I don't think it's for
us to
decide represent H
Haskins with respect we make a lot of
such decisions and for me it's a
conscience
issue I believe what makes us human is
that we are at we are able as sentient
beings to put ourselves in the place of
these Critters I'm not a mouse fan I'm
not a rodent fan but I think these
methods when I hear about cannibalizing
each other and bashing their heads and
we had testimony about drowning them and
the woman said please don't think that
that's more
Humane we don't know what it's like to
drown but we wouldn't want to find out
so we've had this bill in the past
because our constitu
are begging us to pay attention to it
and that is why I was happy to bring It
Forward I think we will
not make it a perfect Bill i' I'd be
open to an amendment but I my conscience
just won't let me alone on this
one representative jman thank you madam
chair uh and and I would say that while
it is true in the end we're talking
about means usually of of killing mice
hopefully with the the have a heart type
traps or the Humane traps you can you
can let them go but a lot of the means
that we use will end up killing the mice
so I I understand where my colleague is
coming from in terms of in the end how
much of this can be really Humane
however we did also receive an email
some of us did from a gentleman who was
testified before the committee before
who has a pest control company who
represents uh that industry and uh and
he is is also very interested Like Us in
not seeing this bill come back again and
again and again and and has said that
this is a means that for him ranks very
very low you know toward the end of the
list of means that he would use to deal
with a rodent infestation and he
supports the idea that uh it's something
that would not be commercially available
as a way to try
to respond to the concerns of our
constituents as representative H Haskins
pointed out that that are not going away
I mean none of us wanted to hear with
the cat declaw bill look this is just
going to keep coming back I understand
that but this is just going to keep
coming back so uh and I think that is an
indication of how much many of our
constituents want this to happen and I
think it's our job to work toward that
goal and if we can find a way to meet
somewhere in the middle uh we'll be
doing the jobs that they sent us here to
do anyone else representative Freeman
thank you madam chair and and it's a
fascinating conversation I'll give you a
little perspective on why I just
intrinsically don't believe this is a
good idea I originally from Boston if no
one can tell and I remember at a time
when they were redoing all the
Subways and I remember standing on a
platform and watching Rats the size of
dogs Scurry through the tunnels they had
such a rodent problem in Boston when
they started digging that they had to
use every tool available in order to
mitigate the rodent problem did they use
glue traps I don't know but I am opposed
to any type of ban on any tool that may
work you in in most situations you go
from the least restrictive to the most
restrictive and I don't see glue traps
as being the first line of defense when
people are trying to combat a rod an
issue so I wouldn't use them I wouldn't
use them because you know it wouldn't be
my preferred method of Exterminating
them but as a legislature and as people
what right do we have to limit how many
tools people have in the toolbox in
order to improve their quality of life
so I mean I'm listening to this
conversation and I really am in taking
all of it in but I just don't think in
my good conscience that I would say no
you can't use those even though you've
tried every other means
possible and and we did hear testimony
from um The Pest Control folks that said
that um these glue traps are more
effective than snap
traps so you know I don't know I mean we
we get a letter from somebody who said
they're not and then we have some
professionals in the field who say that
they are more effective than glue traps
that they they
so I don't know I mean but I and so far
as I'm concerned
um yeah we have a lot of people who want
to see this bill passed uh you know
we've gotten emails and everything
else they won't buy them let the market
decide let them tell their friends don't
buy them but why should we legislate for
people against you know to PE for people
not to be able to buy them if they want
them
especially if they will you know read
the package and and understand not to
put them outside or to check them
frequently or whatever um I I just don't
see uh us taking away a tool for people
who want to use them represent
Penza um thank you madam chair um I've
spent a long time on this project uh or
on this legislation as well reading
listening talking to a lot of people I
think my biggest thing with this um has
to do with the industry so the pesticide
industry
um I would rather um every day of the
week and twice on Sunday that they're
going to use something that is not going
to pollute the environment
and that piece to me um if this could be
just a tool for professional
I'm all for it cuz I know they're not
going to keep them hanging out I know
they're not going to have them suffer
all of those arguments that we've talked
about which are valid but um the one
thing to me is the chemical piece that
is you know harm for uh human health and
other Pet Health and all of that kind of
stuff so um glue traps to me would be uh
you know I would I I can't have that I I
can't see us passing something like that
just because of the industry and uh and
the experts that are using them and I
know that they're using them well so for
that reason in that reason alone to not
be able to use uh you know toxic
chemicals I'm all for them um you know
the we can't control everything and I
get it I mean anybody that would put
these outside or that buys them at you
know um a hardware store or Lowe's or
something like that it's crazy but I you
know I just don't think that this
legislation as possible I mean we can't
control the internet I mean for you can
purchase everything any so what we said
a lot last time last um last term when
this bill came up is education education
is key and you know encouraging of
course you know our department to to
have that this information um online and
you know giving a pat on the back to the
professionals that are pretty much
telling folks you know how you know not
to use these in certain circumstances or
whatever and maybe leaving um you know
if you have a huge infestation you
should be leaving that to the
professionals anyway so um yeah I you
know I appreciate my person on the other
side right there in in in her heart for
this and and I appreciate the arguments
but for that reason and that reason
alone um I'm all chemical free so
representative
Scully thank you Madame chair into
representative penza's Point uh my
concern would be if we try to even limit
this to only the professionals it's
going to mean that the average person is
much more likely to use pesticides and
them not being professionals they're
much more likely to misuse them and we
could actually inadvertently cause
greater contamination to the environment
than you know than just keeping the uh
allowing us to continue to use the glute
traps so for that reason um I
think I I wish we didn't have to kill
any of God's creatures but I think um
it's necessary at times they um endanger
our food supply you know not just by
eating but also by contaminating it and
it it's a necessary thing that we need
to do in order to preserve our selves
and the health of our children so for
that reason I will be voting against
that
bill represent H Haskins thank you madam
chair I just want to remind us that
we're not talking about glue traps
versus
pesticides I think you recall in my
testimony that there are a variety of
mitigation
efforts I could repeat them if anyone
would like to hear them um
for residents homeowners to use that are
not inhumane so I think the pesticide
argument is not gerine to the options
that are available that we now know
including
contraception obviously that doesn't
kill the Critter but if you had an
infestation it would mitigate it for
sure so um exclusionary techniques
habitat
modification Earth kind plant-based
repellent pouches infrared solar power
motion activated techn techology it's
not just glue traps or
pesticides thank
you any other questions comments about
this
bill representative
Bixby so listening to this discussion I
don't think it's going to make a
difference uh if uh we put it in an
amendment or not so I think I'm not
going to go that
direction okay representative wheeler
only thing I would say uh is that
commissioner Jasper did mention that
putting this in the in pesticide control
enforcement under RSA
430 um was the wrong place to have it be
under enforcement so if there was going
to be a floor Amendment it would
probably be a good idea to change where
enforcement was to have the legislation
fit better yep thank you it's a very
good point
all right we're going to move on to uh
HB 171 establishing a moratorium on the
issuance of permits for new
landfills um would anybody like to open
conversation about HB
171 representative
grber uh yes the um I just handed out a
proposed amendment to that bill that uh
changes from a fiveyear moratorium to a
three-year
moratorium um that's based upon
discussion that's that's SE to be uh a
mid Middle Ground among uh the different
length of moratorium that people thought
would be
appropriate um so I just want to make
sure you had a chance to see that
otherwise I did not change any other
language okay uh representa
Scully thank you madam chair um I think
we're doing some very good work in this
Committee in terms of tightening up the
whole um process for citing landfills
and I do think it does it makes sense
for us to have a moratorium to allow the
Department of Environmental Services to
basically catch up with their rules in
order to reflect the good work that this
committee has done I think three years
is far too long for a couple of reasons
one in effect you're tying the hands of
the next legislative session you've made
a decision for them and for some reason
reason they decided they needed to go
forward with the permit they'd actually
in that first year they might have to
undo the legislation in order to allow
them to do that so I don't think we
should be tyed the hands of the next
legislature the other um issue I'm
concerned about is that we've got
another body that this bill has to go
through and we may be able to get it
passed in the house with the three-year
moratorium I honestly believe there
would be almost zero chance that a
three-year moratorium will pass the
Senate I think we could I'm for the
moratorium if we make this a one-year
moratorium with the understanding that
we can come back and we can put it again
for another year if we don't think that
adequate progress is being made but I
think it's a very easy sell uh on the
other side much easier sell on the with
the other body if we make that one year
and I think it also uh the tea leaves
are that the government the governor
would also be in favor of that so um as
it stands I I would not vote for this
bill if the committee is willing to
shorten it to a one-year period I will
vote for it representative brickby yes
thank you madam chair um so uh just as a
matter of of record uh the other body
had does have a moratorium Bill also
theirs is six years uh so um the
one-year moratorium that is proposed is
the governor's uh three years puts us at
a middle ground this is a good
bargaining position the exact length of
the moratorium is not going to be
decided in this committee or in the vote
that we have on the floor uh in a couple
of weeks is going to be probably decided
in a committee of conference towards the
end of the budget process so what we are
doing now is really just setting out a
uh a bargaining position and what we're
doing is we're setting a middle ground
barg bargaining position uh
so uh uh and in terms of you know
whether this could be Revisited in you
know whether we'd be binding a future
legislature well uh if in if in two
years uh it's recognized that we that
all the work for putting into effect the
the other bills we're working on has
taken place in Dees then the next term
that legislature could in fact remove
this you know remove the moratorium uh
it's it's easier to remove something
like a moratorium than it is to extend
it by a year so I think we're better off
by putting it at three years and that
gives us a good baring position it is
amendable by a future future legislature
uh and you know we don't know what's
going to come out of the committee of
conference so that's you know just being
able to bargain is is is really the key
here yes representative Bixby I tend to
agree with that and as a person who at
the beginning of
this
year didn't want to have any moratorium
at
all um and thinking about all of the
work that we have done for the bills
that we are looking at that we we have
done that we've passed I really do think
that three years makes sense uh in in
especially in the scheme of you know
we're talking six years one year we're
in the middle I think that gives this
ample time to really kind of put all of
the rules in place that need to be there
and uh help us catch our Collective
breath and and proceed forward with um
with some really much needed changes to
um the way in which our policy addressed
sighting for landfills and other issues
uh dealing with solid waste so I think a
a three-year moratorium is
sensible uh and yeah it's going to be a
bargain a bargaining chip somewhere
along the line representative ger and
then representative wheeler thank you
madam chair and thank you for those
comments to representative bixby's point
about this is a middle ground kind of
bargaining position it's a middle ground
across the board right the governor has
said one year a Senate bill has it at
six we're at three this is also as Madam
chair pointed out really the culmination
of of a few years of work in this
committee and in the legislature to
build a really broad bipartisan
consensus around the need for a
multi-year moratorium we passed one last
year as well on a Voice vote and that
was on the on the consent calendar
because we had built such a coalition uh
across the the aisles so uh I really do
see this not only as a bargaining
position it's the position of the house
but it also represents a lot of that
hard work to get us to a consensus
position that is very broad across the
body representative
thank you madam chair and I appreciate
everything that's been said about this
being a bargaining chip and just want to
somewhat affirm and add you know we're
only two months into the legislative
session and for us to Cave to the senate
or the governor on our position uh falls
into a tradition that I think is really
sad for the House of Representatives as
of late where we don't respect our
constit tional power as the legislative
body closest to the people and we are
the ones who have heard for hours the
testimony of the people in the North
country and across this state who have
been poisoned by this industry and
frankly you know while I I I 100%
appreciate and I will vote with the
consensus of this committee I mean me
personally I think this state house
given that the Senate has put forward a
six-year moratorium should put forward
something even greater than a six-year
moratorium given that that's what the
people are asking for but I will uh
concede that I think maybe if the house
wants to be the middle ground here then
then that's okay the Senate is usually
the middle ground on these issues so the
Senate putting forward a six-year
moratorium to me shows that that's the
middle ground we could we could push
much farther than that but if we're not
going to do that then we should stand
strong in the consensus that we have
here today around a threeyear moratorium
I think it's a good idea because the
people who have been poisoned by these
terrible decisions that have been made
by the legislature have asked us to do
that representative
guber yes I just wanted to point out
that during this committee's work uh we
did discuss the issue of concerned that
we would not we have plenty landfill
capacity in the state um and this report
by Dees uh I reviewed and show that we
have at least five years Beyond this
moratorium um with already permitted
capacity and as we know about 45% or
nearly half of the waste coming into the
state now being buried is from out of
state um the last thing is that uh Dees
requested that we uh put in some
language which we did put in that uh the
dees can continue to accept information
um evaluate completeness of information
for new landfills but not when would not
act on it so we're not stopping the
process of an individual trying to
develop a new landfill and finally um
this does not apply to uh expansion of
current permitted landfills and looking
at this again report from Dees the
extension ex new sales on currently
permitted landfills that are meeting
environmental standards uh there's great
opportunity that would add easily 10 to
20 more years of capacity for New
Hampshire as well as out ofate waste if
the state decides they want to continue
doing that so I don't think we're going
to run out of capacity so that
in adversity impacts our
industry representative Penza and then
oh representative
Penza thank you madam chair I just um I
had a question um representative guber
about this amendment it um on line 23 it
says here effect July 1 2028 I don't
understand
that may I respond sure absolutely uh
that simply is that uh this bill
uh that has a moror expires on that date
so that refers to the expiration date 3
years from this
summer because it's a moratorium that's
that's the expiration date so section
two is the expiration date that uh that
part of it expires the so the mor term
actually expires on July 1st
2028 section not being shown in the
amendment they often times don't show
the whole bill they just show the so so
if you look at Bill you'll see section
two but if you look in the amendment
they don't show section okay yeah I
don't have all the versions of all the
original pieces but I can't support this
um unless it actually follows the whole
full year of 2028 so and and to be
honest the amount of work that has been
done on we passed this um unanimously
out of our our committee um with the
2028 already uh it went on consent um
you know in a sense if we're doing the
same thing that we did following um you
know last term then it you know we
should have come to 2029 not
2028 um you know I'm willing to work
with the committee on this but I I'm not
willing to do um I'm not willing to do
July you know at this point in time I
just um with the amount of work that has
been put in on all sides of the aisle
here this isn't about stopping a project
I want that to be clear here um there is
so much stuff that needs to happen um
you know us abiding by our you know our
um Solid Waste hierarchy I mean we we
just got the composting stuff in uh you
know we're not us utilizing new
technologies we're like ranked 49th in
the entire country in our in our solid
way stuff um there's a lot of work that
can be done um at Dees uh we have people
right now that are um in a sense
polluting our our special places and and
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done and uh and the only way to do that
is a pause I hate the word moratorium we
we act like you know the the sky is
going to fall it's not going to fall we
are taking in Rochester
55% out of state waste New Hampshire
comes first first that's all we need to
do is say guess what New Hampshire trash
comes first we do not have a problem
with capacity please let's just get that
clear I don't want to hear it again that
that's not a problem we have a problem
of um we have a we have a policy problem
we have a process problem and there's a
lot of really really really great people
that have
sacrificed five six years of their lives
um and some that are on this committee
that have sacrificed the last couple
years um learning living and breathing
this and um and and we can fix it we
just need some time and and uh and
there's a lot of wonderful councils and
committees and people that are that are
all
in like from the opposite ends of the
spectrum like we have come together and
and and looked at science and and time
of travel and all these types of things
to say New Hampshire is a wonderful
special place we can handle these things
we just need it and so I'm not I'm not
willing to sacrifice much on this and uh
and um and I because you know what I'm
not using using any more um New
Hampshire citizens as a bargaining chip
that's for sure so um I don't I don't
work for any special interests I work
for I work for the people in New
Hampshire and it's time we get this done
so representative Bixby yeah so uh just
in terms of just in terms of the the way
that the um the drafting of this sort of
um Bill Works uh the the when there is
going to be repeal of something in the
future the standard way of doing it is
having one uh one section of the bill uh
stating that repeal and and then um and
then have
the effective dat of that set in another
section so uh in the original Bill uh
line 18 section two repeal
RSA uh uh um and basically the 149 m9a
relative to a moratorium on issuance of
permits from uh New Hamshire is new
landfill in new new landfills in New
Hampshire is repealed so uh that is that
is the repeal language and then uh and
then the timing of that is set in
section three which is uh and what the
amendment does is it just moves that to
July 1st 2028 the reason it's July 1st
is because that is the shift of the
fiscal year and off and usually uh bills
are uh when the the period of uh the
active period of Bill is made to align
with the scho year uh so um and that and
if this bill is you know makes it um
well if this bill is passed by both
bodies and signed by the governor before
July that will be a full three years of
um of duration for the for this uh it is
unlikely that this bill will be passed
in this form uh and that is the other
key issue we don't actually know that
uh we if we pass this bill through the
house at three years it is very unlikely
that what comes out at the end of the
process will be three years it may be
higher than that because the Senate may
be pushing for something higher than
that uh and that would be good uh but uh
it is this is a negotiation between two
houses and the governor and we can't
predict how it's going to come out but
if we don't have a strong uh
if we don't have a strong vote on this
in this committee then it's going to
weaken our bargaining position uh so uh
I think I think that uh the the
importance of making sure that we have a
strong approval of there being a
moratorium or a pause however you want
to phrase it is more important than the
exact detail of the number because that
that exact detail is going to be sorted
out in the future
representative ger or Willer were did
you have your hand up before him why
don't you go first and then
representative ger thank you madam
chair my question I suppose is did we
lose votes on the 2030 or why are we
changing it from 2030 to
2028 as I understand there were members
of the committee
here who um who felt that that was a uh
a more appropriate
number could I sure I guess my
position would
be I think that there is a strong
majority of this committee while it may
not come out on the consent calendar
that would vote for 2030
and in my opinion I think that the House
of Representatives should stand stronger
for the position of the people which is
that we want a longer term moratorium
rather than a shorter one rather than
the Senate standing with the people on
this issue and the fact that the Senate
has a stronger bargaining chip than the
house on on this that makes me sad
because the house has generally been the
body which has been able to stand up
strongest with the position that it has
so again I will vote with the consensus
of the committee because I understand
the need for a bargaining chip but I 100
% agree with what representative Penza
had said
and yeah it's I'm having a hard time
using the people of the State of New
Hampshire as a bargaining chip
especially if we're going to do it in
such a low way just for with respect to
everyone's vote on this Committee just
because we lost a couple of votes on the
committee the bargain I mean the when
we're behind closed doors bargaining
with the governor and the Senate which
is long down the line a number one and
being number two when we're doing that
they know what the position of the house
is and because we have a long record of
history of those these bills going
through either on the consent calendar
or with a strong bipartisan majority in
the House of Representatives the fact
that it might not be on the consent
calendar HB
171 to me isn't uh a significantly
weakening of our bargaining chip to to
make it so that I would want to move
forward okay I'm I'm going to add my two
cents here here and the fact that um I'm
not using any citizens in this state as
a bargaining chip I just think 3 years
personally I think three years is a more
um
reasonable amount of time to put a pause
and for me the three years represents
how long it's going to take to get rules
written and put into place and I'm I'm
saying three years because I've seen
with other
legislation legislation that was passed
in 20 22 where rules have still not been
written and uh that's where my my
problem lies in the fact that um this
legislature and uh the
agencies apparently have some difficulty
in getting rules written and getting it
getting things put in place and this has
to do um I'm I'm talking about uh some
of the bills that had to do with
disaster relief uh for our
municipalities
and uh and and and other things that
I've seen so for me this is an issue of
um giving us enough time or at least
trying
to put a pause in place so that we can
get the rules put in place in a proper
fashion that's why I'm I'm going with
three years and I don't think we need
five or six years to be honest but
representative ger thank you madam chair
and I and I want to say also with
respect to to my friends and colleagues
on the committee we're not using the
people as a bargaining chip here in fact
what we're trying to do is create the
best piece of legislation that will
deliver for the citizens of the state
we've been trying to do it for three
years so now that I that I've been on
the committee a little over two years
but uh yeah it's not using them as as a
bargaining chip it's trying to figure
out what the right strategy is going to
be to actually do what they want us to
do and deliver on the protections that
we need I also want to point out that
three years we're looking at not just
the the the rules that have recently
been written but we're looking at four
including the current one four
legislative sessions that we would have
in that three-year period we've got the
current one with some very good
legislation that we hope to get through
one way or another you've got 26 you've
got 27 and you've got 28 so with our
current session and a lot of good
landfill bills we have three more spring
sessions right that we can put in more
legislation if we feel that it is needed
and uh I think that that we've built a
lot of momentum and I'll say the
difference between us and the Senate is
that in the Senate this is a partisan
issue it's not a partisan issue in the
house and it's not a partisan issue in
the house because we have come together
we've done the work we've had the hard
discussions and the hard discussions
have led us to a point where three years
which some of us think is not long
enough some some of us think is too much
but that's why it's not a partisan issue
in the house and I think that our power
comes from our unity and so I hope that
we can continue in that direction and
pass something with a positive statement
that this is not a partisan issue in New
Hampshire if I could just respond Madam
chair just uh sure I just to make it
clear would not want to ascribe motive
to anybody who's done the hard work I
mean I've just joined this committee
been here for two months so I don't
Grant Ed I should have said that at the
beginning I don't know as much as
everyone else I'm just trying to
understand here as far as my position
was is I think a longer moratorium would
be better but I would never ever want to
say that anyone here is not doing hard
work or trying to use the people of the
State of New Hampshire as a bargaining
chip I said that I didn't want to use
the people of the State of New Hampshire
as a bargaining chip I think that chair
Aaron representative Jama you've both
done very hard work and I wouldn't want
to make it seem to the camera to anyone
here that I would say otherwise I would
100% respect your work and that's why
I've said in both the statements that
I've had here at the work
session I will vote with whatever the
consensus of the committee is
representative
Freeman thank you madam chair um I think
and and just as um representative
wheeler stated I'm new to this committee
this is this is not this is not a
committee that I would typically be
familiar with however um when you boil
it all down this is how the sausage is
made
this is how we get things that we need
and what the people of the state need
they've asked us to do this they've
tasked us with this well we we don't
work unilaterally we have to consider
the governor's office and the Senate so
in order to get what we want we have to
be involved in the sausage making
proverbially so while this may not be
what everybody wants or the perfect
thing that they want it's a start and if
we don't start somewhere we don't end
anywhere so to that end I will support
this amendment I will also support the
bill because um I know how much work has
gone into this and I also know that this
is probably the most nonpartisan
Committee in the state house and I want
to keep it that
way represented Penza and then
Howard she was first I'm GNA give it to
her okay sorry I missed that thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
my I'll be brief um I think that um the
only oh sorry um I think that the the
main reason for shortening this the time
span would be to accommodate business or
um rather than to protect the
environment and I think that this this
committee is tasked with Pro protecting
the environment um and and if we don't
give ourselves enough time to make the
rules right and strong then we are not
serving the environment of in the state
in New Hampshire so um I would vote for
I for the longest time that that we can
agree
upon okay represent
penda um thank you um thank you madam
chair and uh thank you for that I agree
yeah I don't believe anyone in this
committee at all or in the house that
have been working on this are you know
the I I know that the word was used and
I think that the word was you know I
hate this word triggering but it was it
was triggering the bargaining chip piece
because um it just seems as if we always
have to do that right we come out with a
piece of legislation and we all agree
and it's perfect and then okay well it
get watered down and then it gets hit
and d and then it's killed and so um the
work that has been done is is um is
Stellar here and yeah there's there's no
one um that I'd rather go to battle with
on all of these things than this
committee so that's not an issue um not
in any way shape or form so I
[Music]
um I just know how hard it is to get
things done through um the legislature
and that's my only concern is
time um chairwoman we could definitely
could we could we do what we needed to
do and get it done in three years I
think we totally could um and and if
everybody's truly motivated and and
committed on that um then then I'm okay
and like I said I'll sign on board I
just I just know how things have kind of
operated um over the last five or six
years so that's why you know the more
time the better to me but however we
could do it I still um I still want it
to carry the whole year um but you know
if this is already you know this is
already in the works and this is
something that we want to get out of um
the committee today and get it um exact
then you know let's get her done okay
represent Scully thank you madam chair I
I actually had a question representative
Bixby you did say that there was a bill
before the Senate asking for a six-year
moratorium uh has that
passed I'm going to defer to
representative J Man on that since he's
been tracking it more
closely uh no what they did is what the
Senate does uh they've held it to see
what we do
may I all right all right and fair
enough um I guess I would say though at
this point six years is not the position
of the
Senate it is not if may I sure just
quick I would say and I agree with that
absolutely statement of fact I would say
the fact that they didn't itl it and
they're holding it to me indicates that
they are open to some link I will it be
six I don't know but they didn't itl it
they're holding it because they want to
see where we come down all right thank
you representative guber uh yes thank
you uh Madam chair um my intention was
never to water down the environmental
value I think we need to we have passed
some terrific uh legislation already uh
bills that uh are going to change things
I just want to get it done and I think
three years uh if we're really going to
get it done we'll have the same output
as if we had five years where well we
don't have to do anything right now we
have another year I think we need to do
the work and get it done and um to
follow up the uh comment on Madam chair
is the the B tment is not to stop
creating new landfills it's to set
standards so that any new landfills meet
the environmental and uh economic needs
of the state thank you representative
Penza I just wanted to thank you madam
chair I just wanted to comment on the
Senate position um only because I spoke
with one of the Senators that is um uh
on the moratorium bill on the Senate
side so just in my time these things
have been originating from the house so
for a bill to have multiple Senators on
it that's originating from the Senate on
a moratorium side is absolutely huge so
I don't that's I think that's why uh
representative Bixby bringing that up um
as well as representative gerana I I we
can't downplay that so it's not the
position of the entire Senate but it's
the position of many members that and
that has not been the case in the past
and I think that is that's very
important to see that that body is
working on something that we've been
trying to um push through and which has
been kind of shut down so that's why
it's really kind of important and um you
know it's there's it's a position of a
lot of people people so that's good
represent Bixby yeah um I'm just
noticing the time here I think we've had
a fairly thorough discussion of um of of
two of
171 oh so um so perhaps uh after we hear
from the uh chair of the subcommittee On
Solid Waste maybe we can move on
yes representative King thank you madam
chair um so everybody here uh has heard
me speak about this before if I had my
DRS the moratorium would last Infinity
years um but um I also recognize the
political reality of the situation um
the sponsor of the bill is fine with
three years I'm fine with three years I
really like the idea of us getting uh
getting this through on consent calendar
I'd rather it not turn into a debate on
the house floor uh if you ask 400 people
how many years it can be it would be
messy and I'd rather it just go through
cleanly um and to throw one possible
Monkey Wrench in the in the gears not
intentionally but it's an honest
question it's not a rhetorical question
um I had um somebody email me a few
weeks ago who apparently is in the
business somehow um and he says there is
a site in Berlin that is really already
a waste Zone it was um an area where I
guess construction or what other type
waste was just dumped there for for
decades and he actually wants to clean
it up and turn it into another landfill
that's going to be a lot better he
doesn't want to use Municipal Solid
Waste he doesn't want anything toxic
it's mostly going to be dirt and um and
wood and other sort of all natural and
he's concerned that this bill would
preclude him from being able to do like
a a
natural landfill so um I guess of the
nice things about a three-year
moratorium is that he would be able to
interject and say Hey I want a landfill
but it's not going to be anything with
toxic materials in it or whatever um so
there there is I guess one of the
benefits of of reducing it down to three
years instead of five is that it would
allow somebody who has maybe let's say a
legitimate reason to build a landfill to
hopefully get his his prospects in with
the rules uh
situation uh and if if somebody else
knows more about that they're welcome to
chime in I'd like to hear it um but um
My Hope also is to just piggyback on
what chairman our chairwoman uh Erin
said that it can take a long time for
them to write rules and so for that
reason I hope representative Scully will
support a three-year moratorium and
allow this to go on consent calendar
because one year just is not enough for
the bureaucrats to write rules so um I
would really like to see this go on
consent calendar thanks thank you okay I
think we can uh wrap up conversation on
HB 171 and I hope that when uh time
comes to exec this bill later on that uh
we can all agree on the amendment and
pass it um moving along we have HB
251 Now for Something Completely
Different allowing for the ownership of
certain squirrels and
raccoons
um I
representative Bixby go right ahead jump
in on this one so I think that um some
of the testimony we heard uh last week
was pretty convincing that this would be
a really bad idea uh like the if you
have a pet squirrel and you need to go
somewhere and get someone to help you
take care of it then you not only need
to have a lot of patience but you have
to have a high pain threshold uh this
this is that sounds really unpromising
uh I think that uh the many people who
wrote an wrote in and said squirrels and
raccoons should not be pets they're wild
animals just have it
right representative
Howard thank you madam chair when I was
a child there was a a book I think it
was even made into a movie about having
a pet um a pet raccoon and even at the
end of that movie he had to set him free
because he just couldn't keep a wild
animal in his in in domestic situation
so I agree with uh representative viby
it's a bad idea
well you know okay I'm I'm just going to
say this
um I mean I wouldn't want to have a
raccoon or a squirrel for a pet but
there are people who do and
um
I I'm really dismayed
that we have our fish and game
department spend time and money in
rehabilitating raccoons and squirrels
that are brought to them
and then if they can't release them back
into the wild for whatever reason they
euthanize them seems like a lot of waste
of time and money for the state to be
doing that and it if if the animal is
rehabilitated and can be kept as a pet
why wouldn't we want to allow somebody
to adopt
it um I'm also I'm I mean especially if
you know you can get care for it and um
you have it under veterinar uh
veterinarian care where they're getting
proper vaccination or whatever they need
um but but I'm also concerned too about
people from other states because there
are are other states that allow these
animals as as pets that if those folks
want to move to New Hampshire they have
to get rid of their pet either euthanize
it or give it away or whatever and um
and I find that kind of sad that people
have to uh get rid of a pet because New
Hampshire doesn't allow them to keep it
so that's kind of my two cents on the
whole issue representative ger thank you
madam chair and I wasn't here for the
hearing but I did watch it uh at home
and remember distinctly the quote that
representative Bixby uh just referred to
I think that the question of
Rehabilitation is opposed to having one
of these animals as a pet to me you're
kind of two separate issues because
Rehabilitation is about the health of
the animal having a healthy raccoon does
not make that raccoon raccoon suitable
to be a pet uh and and what we heard I
think in the testimony was that there
may be some cases where a raccoon or a
squirrel it seems less likely from what
I heard in the case of a squirrel might
eventually be domesticated to the point
where it would make a suitable pet but
the some of the folks we heard from
indicated that most are just not
suitable in the long run for
domestication so to me I hear your point
about the resources that are put into
Rehabilitation and the end result May in
the end still be youth in Asia but to me
Rehabilitation is about the health of
the animal not about domestication and
its suitability to be a
pet I hear you representative Mar
Freeman thank you madam chair um so and
to representative jama's Point um
animals that are rehabilitated may not
be ideal pets but the person who
rehabilitated that pet took the time
time money and energy to rehabilitate
that pet don't you think they should be
allowed to determine if they want to
keep the animal in not instead of having
the animal exterminated I mean I think
this really is um this boils down to uh
uh whether we feel that people can make
those types of decisions for themselves
if they've done everything they can to
rehabilitate this animal they've they
they followed all the rules as far as
vaccinations as far as the health
bringing it to a veterinarian they've
developed a relationship with this
animal want to keep this animal
shouldn't we allow them to do that so I
guess that would be the biggest question
I have about why and and I have to say I
was a little concerned when people
giggled about this bill because I don't
think it's about the animals I think
this is more about a personal um a
personal property issue as well I mean
my as much as I love my dog he's my
personal property and if someone were to
come in and say that I wasn't taken
really good care of him and decide to
exterminate him I would be devastated so
I think we we we need to take a step
back and look at this as not just um a
squirrel and a raccoon but as someone's
personal property and something they've
invested themselves
into respond uh sure representative ger
and then representative Scully yeah I I
take my colleague's point it's a good
one we draw lines between domesticated
and Wild animals all over the place
right in federal law and state law right
and we can disagree on where that line
ought to be drawn uh I I think what it
comes down to is when we're talking
about animals that are wild and were
born in the wild and lived some
percentage of their life in the wild are
they suitable for domestication right
and the question of at what point does
an animal become a pet I would say that
somebody who re rehabilitates a wild
animal does not in the process make it
into a pet and I would say that as there
are reasons why we draw lines between
what is Wildlife as opposed to what is a
domesticated uh pet and and I think from
the evidence that I heard it seemed
clear to me that raccoons and uh
squirrels who begin their lives in the
wild still remain on the wildlife Side
Of The Ledger represent Scully thank you
madam chair well I would say for me um
the idea of keeping raccoons as a pet is
a non-starter that're they're just
they're too big and they're potentially
dangerous and they are much more more
susceptible to rabies now Google is a
dangerous thing so I went on and I did
ask about um squirrel bites and at least
from the what I saw on there they said
that uh they weren't recommending any
type of rabies treatment for squirrels
because there such a low incidence of
squirrels actually Contracting rabies
it's not a a big issue for that animal
so but then again I I don't feel
strongly enough about this that I would
go through the time and effort to try to
re to revise this bill to have it
squirrels only so in its current form I
would vote against it because I don't
think we should be allowing raccoons as
pets if somebody wants to amend this
bill to squirrels I would be open to
it representative Bixby and then
representative King so what we heard
from the uh from the rehabilitators both
who were testifying and uh there a
number of uh people put in online
submissions rehabilitators are against
this bill
because they think that their their
position is that when they are
rehabilitating they are working to keep
the animals able to work into to
function in the wild they do nothing
towards making them more more
domesticated even if that could happen
when the re Rehabilitation is
insufficient to make that animal uh able
to survive in the wild what it means is
that that animal is basically going to
die very soon anyway so euthanasia
versus release is not much difference uh
and they put they they made the attempt
the attempt didn't work so it's time to
say um that the animal is is not going
to make it that is a decision that
rehabilitators know that they're going
to have to make when they get into the
business they and we did not hear from
any rehabilitators that that this that
this was that it was a good idea to try
to make these pets if they failed the
rehabilitation uh we heard Fish and Game
say very strongly no it would be a very
bad idea uh I think that in terms of the
you know the animals that are have that
grew up in the wild have been re there
was an attempt of Rehabilitation and it
failed then we need to go with the
professional advice of if it can't make
it in the wild it's
euthanasia uh in terms of
uh animals that someone might have in
another state and they're moving to New
Hampshire uh it's not quite as clear a
line what I'm concerned about there is
that this could be used as a loophole uh
and someone could go to another state
get an animal that was illicitly uh
obtained from the wild and say oh well I
had this in another state and they bring
it here uh and then we have a problem
and when that when that animal is un
deemed unsuitable for the household then
it goes to the animal shelter which
doesn't know how to deal with it and and
that and that's an an expense for our
animal shelters that they don't really
need to have dumped on them
representative King thank you madam
chair um this is a bill that I had a lot
of mixed feelings about um to start just
to address representative bixby's
concern um to me it seems like if the
animal is incapable of being
rehabilitated enough to survive in the
wild that it should be uh euthanized
that doesn't really follow for me
because we have a lot of animals and
pets that couldn't make it in the wild I
mean people own rats that if you were to
release it they would be easy prey
because they've been so domesticated for
so long uh chickens I mean there's a lot
of animals that if we just let them out
in the wild they'd get eaten up real
quick so to me it's like okay if you
rehabilitate an animal and it's still
not good enough to survive in the wild
then that to me seems like a candidate
for keeping the pet um that being said
um I definitely do sympathize with the
idea that so there's two situations here
are we concerned about the humans or are
we concerned about the the the animals
because on the one hand we have well you
know they might have rabies and that
might bite somebody for me that's a risk
that the owner would be willing to take
I'm not concerned about the humans
really I'm more concerned about the
animals um to me personally I've always
had a problem with the idea of owning
caged animals I think it's really weird
owning Birds personally and we allow
that I mean you've taken everybody says
free as a bird the the bird is like the
most free spirited animal on planet
Earth and we capture it from the Amazon
and we ship it to some kid here in the
state so it can be stuck in a cage its
whole life I mean that's totally
inhumane and we allow that so if if we
if we can allow that I feel like
raccoons and squirrels is a no-brainer
especially because these animals you
know they they seem to get along with
humans a little better um you let a bird
out it's going to fly away unless it's a
paragan falcon or something it's gone uh
so but squirrels and raccoons they might
actually come back to the people that
own it so I think the idea that we're
operating in the best interest of the
animal by killing it that doesn't make
any sense to me whatsoever and the and
and then the idea that like well we have
to kill it for the humans eh let them
take that risk so I mean I have very
mixed feelings about this um but I think
I would personally I tend towards aing
on the side of freedom and the idea
that's just like the government should
be dictating well these animals can be
owned and these animals can't be owned I
say leave it up to the people um but I
do personally ethically I think it's
very weird owning animals that really um
I just think I just think they shouldn't
be owned by people but then again you
know you've got St Francis of AI and he
had all these creatures come to him and
and they seem to get along fine could
you imagine stealing these creatures
from St Francis of CCE and executing
them I don't think a lot of people would
go for that I mean we wouldn't even have
him he wouldn't even be the hero that he
is if we' had done that so so anyways
that's my two all right um I'm in the
interest of time I mean we've got uh one
two three four five six seven eight nine
more bills to talk about before 11:00 I
don't know how you know
what how we wanted do this um
so can we just skip to the next bill and
we can we can take up discussion about
this next week as well or tomorrow even
if you want um HB
263 excuse me um relative to the
applications to the cost of care fund
for livestock
care um I believe that uh with testimony
last week we heard that um that bill
should be rolled into the bill that
we're going to hear this afternoon so uh
the plan I guess would be to to
um uh itl that bill uh correct I think
that makes the most sense okay any
question on
that uh HP 277 relative to the use of
the term F and Colt representative Bixby
this bill is basically just correcting
an existing error in statute language uh
I hope there's no opposition to it
no okay we are we are going to um exec
that bill out today HB 307 relative to
the food production area for Homestead
food representative Bixby you have an
amendment on that yes so I have an
amendment on this that I passed around
this amendment was largely proposed by
our uh constituent Addie uh zus
something like that uh Dave uh um zavos
zavos zavos yeah uh and uh and then I um
I brought it I uh ran it by food
protective services and uh they had uh
had a chance to look at it as well
before then and uh oh they had oh sorry
um so but I I then uh I did run it by
food protective services and they
suggested that um that the uh that it
that we add a section on making sure
that the floors and walls and ceilings
were hard surfaces uh and this is it
came back from uh OS in a slightly
different format than I sent it to them
but I think it is simply the way that
they uh felt that it was most efficient
to put it in statute by setting things
up as uh a general directive followed by
a set of definitions as opposed to a set
of a set of General directives uh so um
my sense is that this bill is uh ready
to go with the amendment um I it will
the basic idea of what it does is it
says that you can if you have the right
sanitary facilities you can set up a a
secondary place in your home for food
production that is not a kitchen one of
the advantages of this is that uh it
that secondary uh location May in fact
be uh better for isolating the food
production process from children pets uh
Etc and uh and husbands who want to eat
your
cookies so uh so uh I I does anyone have
any questions about it no representative
guber uh yes I just want to uh
compliment you I think this is what the
homestead food producers will really
appreciate it's clear basic functional
sanitation everything's here so highly
supportive yes and and I would like to
thank Addie zos where if she happens to
be listening in to uh for the great com
contributions she made to this thank you
so much for your work on this it's great
really
great um moving along we'll uh talk
about HB
396 exempting meat and meat food
products slaughtered and prepared in
state for
sale in state from certain
inspections um I think what we decided
with that bill was uh first of firstly
um since you know we're dealing with uh
federal law here and we don't want to
um as the commissioner had said we
didn't want to put our farmers in Peril
of getting fined or hauled off to jail
for doing this against the law and
despite the fact that we perhaps do that
with um cannabis and other things um we
thought it would be more prudent to
retain this
bill and um I have penned a letter I
which I'll pass out to
everybody
um to our federal
delegation oh I don't have it with me I
have something else um
I will be pinning a um or the committee
committee is doing a letter to the
federal delegation right yeah I think
that what we are the approach was we
were going to I think you're mixing this
up with a different with the res we have
a resolution so so the idea is that uh
we will ask for rule suspension for late
drafting of a resolution exactly yeah
and and also and that resolution is will
be something that is just voted on by
the house it's a house resolution so we
don't the Senate doesn't do resolutions
for some reason so uh so it's going to
be house resolution uh and uh we have a
draft uh idea of that resolution from
the Farm Bureau which um representative
Aon and I are going to sit down and edit
significantly y uh and to make it so
that there are not 20 whereas Clauses
right and uh and then we are hoping that
that resolution is something that can
pass easily with on on the house because
we're going to try to get leadership on
both sides to uh help us with that
motion right okay uh and I I I think the
letter you're think yes for a different
bill yeah
yeah okay so yeah So the plan is to
retain that bill and then uh we have
this joint
resolution um and
that's one one quick note on that on
that ret retention um the reason we're
retaining it rather than it yelling it
is because if by some chance the federal
government manages to get a bill out
that will would allow us to do something
we'd have a vehicle to work with yeah
yeah me see okay uh moving along to HB
55 allowing the sale of freeze-dried
foods produced in Homestead food
operations uh the sub commmittee the
food safety subcommittee met this
morning um
I let's see this
was okay so that's 505 the freeze-dried
food so I drafted up um some language
that I've shared with
everybody and
um the committee the subcommittee
discussed this and
um basically we made a couple of changes
to this as well so I'm going to take
these changes and submit them to OS to
make an amendment that we can talk about
next week but
basically we I I've added a whole new
section rather than the simplistic one
that uh representative shamberg
presented to us last week um this whole
new section basically
says uh gives you know how um the the
the protocol to making Freez dried foods
um and that we could we could allow for
cut up fruits and vegetables under
certain things if they do certain things
we would not allow Tomatoes or melons
because those are very um high content
in water I've taken a lot of this
information Direct directly off the USDA
website on how uh freeze-dried foods
should be
prepared um we have a section that would
allow freeze-dried meats that raw meat
would not be
freeze-dried um you would have to cook
the meat and then freeze dry it that's
something that you know that we should
as a committee think about if we want to
allow freeze-dried meat um vegetables
and fruits and
also I had another section in here uh
other foods that are permissible to be
freeze-dried are already commercially
prepared foods including ice cream and
yogurt we had samples of the ice cream
last week so and they they testified
that they bought commercially uh
produced food that was already safe for
consumption they just freeze-dried it
and want to be able to sell it so those
are the um the the ways the things that
could be freeze-dried and how they
should be freeze-dried um we want to add
in a
um some language oh yeah we also have
about how it should be sold it's only
sold within New Hampshire from Farm
stands and so forth um how it should be
packaged and
labeled
um and that's basically what we have for
that representative Bixby and then
wheeler have you had a chance to run
this by food Protective Services I have
not I was going to discuss that with
them as well okay
yeah representative wheeler was going to
say thank you for writing the amendment
I had tried that Freeze stried ice cream
I ended up giving it to my baby cousins
it was just left me wanting real ice
cream I tried it I this is just almost
good but I thought it was not not quite
but it is I really appreciated them
coming forward and I think finding out
some way to make it so they can run
their business easier is a good way to
go forward thank you any other
comments okay thank you so then moving
on to H be 505 uh
642 okay allowing the sale of dehydrated
meat I've also passed out um a proposed
amendment and it's just basically fixing
uh some of the things that were left out
of the um original bill from OS drafting
they had made a mistake in the first
part um saying that a meat producer
distributor who has a license to sell
USDA inspected meat may sell us da
inspected meat if it has been
freeze-dried well that this is not a
freeze-dried bill so we had that struck
out and I would put the word dehydrated
in there
um we want to also add in that meat
would be dried in an NSF certified food
dehydrator as opposed to any old food
dehydrator so that way that makes sure
that um you know we we have a um
a an item that they're using in their
production that is um you know certified
for using it for that purpose and then
um I added a portion that was
highlighted on this copy that was also
left out in drafting that limits the
amount of freeze-dried of dehydrated
meat that they could produce and sell so
um that would ensure that they're not
that they're keeping their batches small
and that they're not you know making so
much that they're not uh they would be
more it's a matter it's a matter of
really controlling the risk of foodborn
illness so um representative Miner thank
you chairman excuse
me thank you chair chairwoman uh Aon I
think you've done a great job on this
amendment a lot of thought has gone into
this and I want to thank you for taking
the time to do it thank you
any other
questions represent Bixby I'm just not
seeing where you have the what line the
the uh NSF it's not in there we we added
that in in the subcommittee okay so so
this is something so that's that's to be
to be added to be added yes yep
okay and I will go through both of these
uh amendments with you guys just to see
your get your thoughts on it
so uh all right moving on to
hb77 representative Penza what do you
have for us on
that thank you madam chair I had sent
around um electronically changes to 707
and then I um of course had them printed
as well um for that work session I don't
have this definitely not enough copies I
didn't get more um I kind of held on to
these so I can pass these around again
um for people that want them in front of
them while we could talk about it um the
um the only changes that are going to be
made to
707 um versus the you know all the red
lines that I had already worked on um is
adding in the lee8 component which um
represented
um ger is going to give me the language
for um we have um you know and I'd like
to talk about that here to see if it's
um if it's necessary um or not to
possibly um
modify um 10 to the 10 to the5 if we
were going to cons can um um consider
making that 10 to the4 for I don't know
if we necessarily need to do that only
because um if we're looking to uh do a
specific carve out for expansions then
um those
um in with certain rules and criteria of
landfills that are currently operating
not not that they would necessarily be
um grandfathered in um it would be more
so that they are running in full
compliance they want to open up a cell
there's still um uh multitudes of areas
of new technology in regards with liner
and all of that that will still be fall
under the current 800 rules that are in
place um and and then if it's about
certain things that have to do with
setbacks um you know if that landfill is
in like I said in full
compliance um then there's other um
there's other pieces that um could be
brought in let's say for example um clay
that could get make them um less uh less
time of travel and those types of things
so um I don't I don't foresee any
changes any further changes to 707 than
what I've put forward except for maybe
um5
to4 um as well as
um the leech 8 piece and then even
possibly removing the one line um in a
sense that
is um that's actually think I'm on page
page it's
on
um it's the one it's the one um
disclaimer in regards with expansions so
Al other than that I don't um I don't
have any other changes to 707 at this
point all of the all of the work and the
fixes have been
done okay representative gerana thank
you madam chair thank you representative
Penza for all the hard work that you've
you've put into this um so I I have as
representative Penza pointed out uh I
have I'm in the process of working on
some language regarding the lee8
transfer area uh and protections around
that uh I have reached out to director
whimet and and we've started to
correspond it's it's a complicated issue
and I'm in the process with the the
director of looking through what's
currently in rules regarding safety
Protections in that lee8 transfer area
so I don't know if it's possible for us
to do with the the lee8 transfer area
and the 10 to theg 5th or 10 to the
ne4th if it's possible for us to do a
solid waste subcommittee meeting perhaps
next week to talk about those two issues
so that we can then bring it to the
committee with a consensus around those
two issues in
particular well that sounds like a plan
yep I just want to remind you though
um yeah all bills are due out of
committee March
20th um we have um we have a schedule
for
tomorrow um we have um Tuesday March
11th
I wanted to ask the committee that's
town meeting day I I have already
thought uh planned that we would meet
from 9:30 till 12 to do a committee work
session on certain bills and have a
brief time for caucus and then exec some
other bills
out and we would be done by noon does
anybody have a problem with meeting on
town meeting
day
no no okay all right so we'll we'll
proceed with that otherwise we would
have to meet on a Monday or the
Wednesday that week
um but I you know I don't want to get
too too close to March 18th which is the
Tuesday which is two days before
everything has to be done so if we can
get everything wrapped up by next week
um and meet we could possibly meet again
Wednesday March 12th if we need to exec
out any other remaining bills that we
have but um
that's the plan so okay you guys if you
want to do further work on 707 that
would be
fine okay I guess
the I'm I'm wondering if the solid way
subcommittee will be able to have a
complete Amendment on
707 by uh by that time but by next week
I don't know I hope
so
really it's just the Lee piece really um
uh we I mean if we have the if we have
that language buttoned up then it'll be
inserted and we should have that um
forward I don't have a calendar in front
of me um can you tell me the dates of
the next couple Tuesdays so
the next next week of course is March
11th Y and then um there's also an
opportunity for us to meet on Wednesday
March 12th uh Tuesday March 18th we have
the New Hampshire Farm Bureau young
breakfast farmer
breakfast so um you know it's possible
for us to come in here and exea Bill out
if we need to do that um okay so you
know we have have that that at our at
our disposal I mean we have we can meet
any days I mean other than
Thursdays represent Miner thank you
madam chair I think we're almost there I
think the subcommittee is doing an
excellent job on this thing and I think
we'll we'll absolutely have this U exact
by um um by next uh committee
meeting representative gerana yes thank
you uh yeah I I appreciate that V of
confidence and I agree representative
King has has done a great great job of
uh working with that subcommittee uh and
and I think yeah we can prepare whatever
amendments and have them to present at
the for discussion at the subcommittee
meeting and then be able to move ahead
to the whole committee I think it's just
important to have some consensus among
that bipartisan group and then bring it
together to the committee but we can
have those amendments prepared for next
week and then have them prepared for the
whole committee for next week yeah and
then the goal would be execute on on the
18th then well if we can execute on the
11th we can execute on the 18th perfect
okay okay representative Scully thank
you Madame
chair would it be possible
to um involve the dees again to create
another GIS map to see what the
Practical result or impact is of the new
uh setback restrictions when he did that
for the first bill and it became quite
clear that it it there were so many that
it basically made citing a landfill in
New Hampshire practically impossible
well I'll ask him thank you yep okay um
moving on to HB 779 allowing the sale of
rabbit meat in interstate commerce
represent Bixby okay so uh this bill
came to us as uh a good idea that was
badly executed uh and uh the
commissioner of um uh uh commissioner
jff Jasper pointed out how a lot of the
uh references in statute were just
really off base uh the good idea part of
it is we already have a system for doing
uh for selling uh farm raised rabbit New
Hampshire farm raised rabbits to
restaurants and there's a mechanism for
training to make sure that people know
what they're doing when they do that uh
and uh so I uh consulted with
commissioner Jasper about where this
should sit in statute he pointed out
that according to the
USDA the so uh rabbit is considered a
non-amendable species so it's not
governed by USDA Slaughter rules uh the
usda's position on rabbit meat is that
as long as it is dealt with uh
conforming with state health food safety
laws then it is accept able uh to the
USDA so uh what I did was I basically
created another section underneath the
statue that allows sale to restaurants
uh that also allows sale to uh uh sale
at a farm stand at a farm or at a
farmer's market as long as it meets the
uh correct Protections in terms of
making sure that it is packaged
correctly that it is trans uh
transported safely to where it's going
to end up uh and that it is labeled
correctly and that whoever is doing this
has the um has taken the uh rabbit and
poultry uh um production course that is
uh offered by Cooperative Extension
several times a year uh so uh it's uh
the um the resulting amendment is a fair
simpler than the original Bill and uh I
also ran this by food safety uh uh
services and they caught a couple of U
drafting errors that I had made which
for which I thank them and um but said
that it is basically uh workable uh with
the
corrections okay sounds good I'm looking
forward to supporting that bill and its
Amendment and last but not least
hr13 representative ger you were working
on an amendment for that yes thank you
madam chair and it is coming around so
this is an amended version of an
amendment of an
amendment uh and hopefully we've got the
we've got it now U so as you can see
it's been dramatically reduced we have
three warehouses uh and they are all
specific to Forest L Forest Lake orb the
North country in the case of the second
whereas and this was a product of a lot
discussions with members about what they
wanted to see in the um in the final
version so I hope I hope we've gotten
there representative ger thank you so
very much this looks absolutely
wonderful to
me I look forward to supporting
this okay with that we are done uh with
our work session and uh I would now like
to adjourn our work session and and take
some time for both of our sides to meet
in caucus and uh discuss who's going to
make what motions and so forth and um so
we'll see you back here at
uh 11 11:20 yeah all right just take
take a
break all right
all
right
okay um for you
guys can I see you sometime like during
lunch or something or when are when are
you going to be available
yeah I wanna I want to just go over
these y um since Catherine's not
here okay okay
okay
e
e e
all right welcome back everybody and we
are getting ready now I'm going to open
up um our exec
session on HB 171 establishing a
moratorium on the issuance of permits
for new
landfills and do I hear uh a motion yes
uh Madam CH representative guber I
recognize you to make a motion thank you
madam chair I'd like to move OTP for hb1
HB
171 with Amendment
d04
65h do I hear a
second representative Freeman oh thank
you
okay representative guber would you like
to speak to your motion um uh we
discussed it uh quite a lot earlier
today um I think uh we uh find that this
is what's needed for the State of New
Hampshire at this time to move forward
with our Solid Waste Management okay
thank you do I hear any discussion
further no see none I'd like the uh
clerk to call the role for uh the
amendment
2025-the
yes representative Penza
yes representative Freeman
yes clerk votes
yes representative
Scully representative Barber yes
representative Miner
yes representative Bixby
yes representative
ger
yes representative has Haskins
I representative Howard
yes representative wheeler yay
representative guber yes cheran Aaron
yes 13 to1 motion
passes okay do I hear a motion for
otpa representative guber uh question uh
can this be placed on the consent
calendar well we have to we have to vote
on the OT
we voted on the amendment now we're
voting on The
TPA then i' like to uh move uh to pass
for the bill with the amendment um HB
171 okay I'll second that thank you
representative
Freeman any
discussion seeing none um the clerk can
call the
role on otpa for HB 171
representative Kenny yes representative
Penza yes representative Freeman yes
clerk votes yes representative Skully no
representative Barber
yes representative Miner yes ranking
member
Bixby
yes representative germana
yes representative Askins
I representative Howard yes
representative wheeler yay
representative guber yes chairwoman
Aaron yes motion passes
13-1 and do I hear uh can we put this on
the consent calendar as the only no vote
I do not object to this being put on
consent thank you very much and I think
that would be entirely appropriate yes
thank you very much I appreciate app
that and uh representative guber I look
forward to your committee
report okay I'll close out the exec for
HB 171 and open up the exec for HB 263
relative to the applications to the cost
of care fund for livestock
care and I would like to move
itl do I hear a second I second thank
you representative H Haskins and I will
speak to my motion um and we discussed
in the work session um and before when
when we heard the bill um any of this um
language for the cost of care fund uh
would be an appropriate Amendment
into excuse me another bill that we're
going to hear this
afternoon um so I um am am fine with
Elling this bill and uh and having
having this language put somewhere else
where it's more
appropriate any
discussion represent vict I concur with
that thank you okay um so motion is itl
and I would like the clerk to call the
role please representative Kenny
yes representative Penza yes
representative Freeman yes clerk votes
yes representative Scully
uh yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner yes ranking member
Bixby
yes representative germana
yes representative H Haskins I
representative Howard yes representative
wheeler yay representative guber yes
chairwoman Aaron yes 14 nothing motion
passes okay any objection to putting
this on consent that would be
appropriate thank
you I'm closing out HB 263 exec and
opening HB 277 exec relative to the use
of ter and fa uh the ter relative to the
use of the term F and Colt do I hear a
motion representative Howard thank you m
chair I move to ought to pass on HB
277 do I hear second yes I'll second
them representative Kenny seconds would
you like to speak to your motion
representative Howard very briefly okay
I I think that the author of this bill
did not mean to leave out half of the
horse population so we're just
correcting the language thank you yes
all right um I direct the clerk to call
the role for o2p motion on HB
277 representative Kenny yes
representative Penza
yes representative Freeman yes clerk
votes yes representative Scully yes
representative Barber yes representative
Miner yes ranking member Bixby yes
representative germana yes
representative H Haskins I
representative Howard yes representative
wheeler yay representative Gruber yes
chairwoman Aaron yes 14 nothing motion
passes thank you
any objection to putting this on the
consent calendar consent is good thank
you closing out HB 277 exec and opening
up HB 307 exec for relative to the food
production area for Homestead food do I
hear a motion yes I'd like to move um HB
307 with Amendment uh um 2025
d655 h do I hear a second yes I'd like
to second that thank you representative
barar and um representative Bixby would
you like to speak to your motion so uh
we essentially covered the amendment in
the um in our uh work session but the
basic idea is that what this uh what the
what the what the bill does with this
amendment is creat a food production
area in the home uh that is not the
kitchen uh that follows certain sanitary
requirements which have been uh vetted
by the food protective services and they
think that it's good uh so I hope
everyone will support the
amendment thank you I look forward to
supporting the amendment and the
otpa uh so hearing no other discussion I
uh direct the clerk to call the role on
um accepting the amendment
for uh 2025-the
5H for HB 307 representative Kenny yes
representative Penza yes representative
Freeman yes clerk votes yes
representative Scully yes representative
Barber yes representative Miner yes
ranking member Bixby yes representative
germana yes representative Haskins I
representative Howard yes representative
wheeler yay representative Gruber yes
chairwoman Aaron yes 14 nothing motion
passes thank you and do I hear a motion
for otpa on this bill representative
Bixby I would like to move otpa uh for
House Bill 307 with Amendment 0 uh two
0655 okay do I hear a second on that yes
I'd like to second that thank you
representative Barber any
discussion seeing none I would direct
the uh clerk to call the role on otpa
motion for
hp37 with the amendment 2025-the
representative Barber yes representative
Miner yes ranking member Bixby yes
representative germana yes
representative H Haskins I
representative Howard yes representative
wheeler yay representative Gruber yes
chairwoman Aaron yes 14 nothing motion
passes thank you and any objection to
putting this on consent calendar consent
is good thank you I'm going to close out
the exec for HB
307 and I will open up the exec for HB
396 exempting meat and meat food
products slaughtered and prepared in
state for sale no in state for sale in
state from certain
inspections I am going to move that we
retain this
bill do I hear a
second I second that you second oh oh H
Haskins okay thank you representative H
Haskins and um as we discussed before we
are going to retain this bill just to
see what happens from the federal level
uh and in the meantime uh we are going
to prepare a joint
resolution uh to be presented to the
house uh representative Bixby you are
going to um work on that resolution yes
so uh well we have a resolution we're
working on to work on um and we also
need to work with our leadership to make
sure that we do the rules exception
correct so um do we have any discussion
on retention motion no seeing none um
going to ask the clerk to call the role
on motion to retain HB
396 representative Kenny yes
representative Pat
yes representative Freeman yes clerk
votes yes representative
Scully yes representative
Barber yes representative Miner yes
ranking member Bixby
yes representative germana yes
representative H Haskins I
representative Howard yes representative
wheeler yay representative Gruber yes
chair Roman Aaron yes 14 nothing motion
passes thank you I'm going to close out
the exec for HB
396 and open up the exec for HB
779 allowing the sale of rabbit meat in
interstate commerce do I hear a motion
yes I would like to uh move uh HB uh 77
779 FN ought to pass with Amendment uh
225-0686
47h do I hear a second yes I like to
second that
motion yes I'd like to second that
motion
okay and uh We've covered this pretty
well but what this does is it basically
creates um the the capacity for someone
to sell up to a thousand rabbits in a
year as long as they uh have the
training course that is available
through Cooperative Extension register
with the Department of Agriculture and
and um and follow the rules that are uh
set out for
this okay any other further
discussion thank you again for your work
on this bill representative Bixby um I I
look forward to supporting the amendment
and the Bill thank you so much oh you're
welcome um i' would like to have the
clerk call the role on the amendment for
HB 779 which is 2025
647h representative Kenny yes
representative Penza yes representative
Freeman yes clerk votes yes
representative Scully yes representative
Barber yes representative Miner yes
ranking member Bixby yes representative
germana yes representative H
Haskins I representative Howard yes
representative wheeler
yay representative guber
yes chair Roman Aaron yes 14 nothing
motion
passes okay do I hear a motion for otpa
on this bill iby I move otpa on uh HB
779 with Amendment 2025-the
seconds any
discussion I think we've covered it
we've covered it all uh so I direct the
clerk to call the role for a motion of
otpa with on HB 779 with the amendment
47h representative Kenny
yes representative Penza
yes representative Freeman yes
thir votes yes representative Scully yes
representative
Barber yes representative Miner
yes ranking member Bixby yes
representative germana yes
representative H Haskins I
representative Howard yes representative
wheeler representative Gruber yes
chairwoman Aaron yes 14 nothing passes
thank
you okay I'm going to close out the
exact on HB oh I'm sorry would you like
to put that on consent I think consent
would be good okay thank you we will
have that on the consent calendar thank
you I'm going to close out the exec for
HB
779 and open up the execs for
hr13 uh house resolution 13 opposing the
permitting of a landfill next to Forest
Lake Park in Dalton New
Hampshire do I hear a
motion yes Madam chair representative
German thank you very much uh I move uh
ought to pass on hr13 with amendment
2025-the
I think this makes a powerful statement
on behalf of the committee and uh it
will make a powerful statement on behalf
of the house we also have had a
statement uh on the part of the governor
so I think we've got a lot of consensus
around this important issue and I thank
uh every member of uh the committee who
has contributed to getting us to this
document we can all
support
okay um any other further
discussion seeing none I would like the
clerk to call the role on uh
hr13 with the amendment 2025-the
on on this amendment I'm sorry
representative Kenny yes representative
Penza 100
yeses representative Freeman
yes clerk votes yes representative
Scully yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner absolutely ranking
member Bixby
yes representative germana yes
representative H Haskins I
representative Howard yes representative
wheeler yay representative Gruber
yes chair Roman Aaron yes absolutely
motion passes 14
nothing okay um now I guess we are
looking for a motion for otpa on hr13 do
I hear representative ger thank you
madam chair I move otpa on hr13 with
Amendment
2025-the
role for otpa on hr13 representative
Kenny yes representative
Penza yes sir re representative Freeman
indubitably CL votes yes representative
Scully yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner resounding yes
ranking member Bixby yes representative
germana yes representative H Haskins I
representative Howard yes representative
wheeler
yay representative guber Very Yes chairl
manarin Yes motion passes 14 nothing
okay I'd like to have that on the ENT
calendar um sure sure
okay um and with that I'm going to close
out the ex exec session for
hr13 and we are done executing bills for
today so I would remind those who are um
made the
motion to submit um reports to me the
committee reports so for HB 171 we have
representative guber
for uh
HB 263 I guess that's me uh 277 for the
fen Colt Bill
representative Howard I can't make any
promises and then HB 307 relative to
food production area for Homestead food
that would be represented
Bixby uh I will be doing the report for
HB
396 and HB 779 representative Bixby for
the rabbit meat Bill and on
hr13
for that uh is uh representative
germanna so please get those reports to
me as soon as
possible and we are done with our exec
session we will be meeting back
here at 130 No 1
o'clock okay well no though so 1 o'
clock we're going to be coming back here
to talk about the language that's in HR
uh 2 the trailer
Bill uh and have some discussion about
that and and some POS you know make some
possible plans with that and then we
have uh HB
616 hearing at 1:30 this
afternoon I will be introducing the bill
my vice chair is out today so
um representative Bixby has graciously
um agreed to run the hearing while I
introduced the bill so um we'll see you
then right oh and there is a card for
representative contor chairman Aaron
chairman Aon yes sir I've uh I've gotten
um invitation I think the whole
committee did to a breakfast uh for a
future Farm uh of America are we are we
going as a group yes okay thank you well
we are
are is it the young farmer breakfast on
the 18th no I think it's the Future
Farmers of America FFA oh I have an
invitation which I'll bring with me uh
well I'll send you the information I I
probably have that at home okay in my
mail it's a Tuesday I know that is it is
the 18th of Tuesday yeah
well I could very well young Farmer's
breakfast could very well be I could be
mistaken it's in London der I believe
okay I'm mistaken okay so we'll all be
there good hopefully sinder um yeah I'll
send out a reminder it'll be okay Jamie
maybe I get a lot of those invitations I
delete so I don't know what we're going
to and what we're
not
extra okay
all
right one o' considered a work session
the one one o'clock is considered a work
session
um and I also have for you
guys um a letter that I wrote to um
commissioner
Quinn regarding um hb1
153 which was the one where we wanted to
have two or more law enforcement
officers in each County received
training so in lie of that I mean
um we didn't pass that bill correct
turned it into a study Comm we turned it
into a study committee but we also
wanted to write a letter to commissioner
Quinn to ask him
um
uh well I'll let you read the letter
because there's a lot lot of things here
um and um you can get back to me as to
whether you think you want to uh if this
is fine or not okay so just passed a
couple here you just use language I you
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah all right have a good lunch we'll
see you
later oh I won't tell you what to do
I so do we need to discuss
anything
e
e e
environment
agriculture I'd like our members to
please take their seats
thank
you all right so committee members I
just wanted you to be aware I received a
communication from the chairman of the
house committee on
finance uh representative
Wier and he writes dear chairman Aaron
as you know the enabling bill for the
budget hb2 often includes policy changes
which affect the spending in
hb1 these Poli policy changes would
affect functions of which your committee
has
oversight sometimes this is a reflection
of bills already in your committee but
sometimes it is a complete
restructuring before the finance
committee passes hb2 I would like your
input as to your agreement with the
changes or some adjustments you would
prefer some chairs give me a report
based on their own experience Others May
want full committee input I want full
committee put I leave that to your
discretion I do however need your
comments by March 15th so we have until
March 15th to um communicate back to the
chairman of
Finance our thoughts about what was in
uh hb2 I did hand out a hard copy to
everybody and also
electronically of the 10 about 10 pages
were
of um new
language that uh was included in
hb2 in the governor's
budget um it has to do with
creating a solid waste site evaluation
committee hang
on
and um all the
all
the pieces of of
that now um I hope everybody has taken
some time to take a look at it read it
and uh come today with your
comments about what we should or should
not do with this language that's in hb2
and that's the purpose of this half hour
discussion before we go into the hearing
for uh HB
616 so um would anybody like to start
the
conversation regarding the uh the um
language that was included in hb2
Representatives uh
King thank you madam chair um I just
have a couple little things that I just
thought were interesting questions
really if um everybody would like to
turn to page two it's the first it's the
first back of page one it says page
15 and you go to
Roman hang
on okay let me
see
if people don't have copies okay hang on
let me
see no worries no worries that's
okay let me see if I have any
extras I did send it in an email
this is what it looks
like okay um um
um use
myop you folks have a copy you have one
you want me ask Jamie if she make a few
copies yes
please
okay uh let me see if I have
any you don't have any extras I don't
have any okay
no lar
okay
okay all right um
well okay should I continue but you can
I guess you can continue is that okay
yeah yeah
okay so um it's uh page two which is
labeled as page 15 it's just the the
back of page one and uh it goes through
all the the Roman numerals and it's
basically it's giving you the
definitions so that when we build the
rest of the the bill I guess you call it
it it we know what the definitions are
and uh on Roman numeral 8 uh major solid
waste disposal facility means a location
system or physical structure for the
collection separation storage transfer
processing treatment or disposal of
solid waste with a proposed waste
acceptance rate of greater than 100,000
tons per year and then this is the part
that I
circled okay and then the part I circled
is the last L last sentence it says
major solid waste disposal facility does
not include any facility proposed to be
constructed by a New Hampshire municipal
government and I guess one of the
concerns I don't know somebody can maybe
address this and it's not a concern at
all but what I'm concerned about is you
know it's not a guarantee that every
landfill is going to be privately run it
could potentially be that a municipality
runs a landfill in which case this whole
bill and all the rules and restrictions
and and and everything they put in there
would be moot because it's run by
municipality so it seems like almost a
sort of a a loophole to get around a a
new landfill because it doesn't meet the
definition of a major solid waste
disposal facility so it sounds like it
looks like rep uh representative Bixby
might have a response I'd love to hear
it yeah I would like to thank you for
noticing that uh because uh one of the
things um last term we had a bill that
would have banned private landfills and
they would all have to have been public
but they could be run by a private
uh management company and this would
basically uh create a a real gap for a
priv a publicly owned landfill that was
run by a private company uh and uh so I
and I think you know the fact that it's
owned by publicly or privately doesn't
change the uh potential potentially
problematic uh contents of a landfill or
the problematic area ideas about you
know where that stuff men make may end
up if it's not properly cited so I I
think that I don't think this exemption
makes
sense okay
so major solid waste disposal facility
does not include any facility proposed
to be constructed by a New Hampshire
municipal government so you're
saying what about a public owned
landfill run by a private whether it's
owned by the privately or publicly I
mean it just seems like a loophole here
if the if it's constructed by New
Hampshire municipal government then
everything we read in the next 10 pages
or so is like moot y okay that's my
concern okay
gotcha
um grber and then Penza thank you thank
you I just have a few overall comments
uh under the very the beginning the
first sentence Declaration of
purpose just one minute anybody else
don't have a copy my cop you can use
your copy back there anybody else over
you need a
copy you're all set
okay thank you for doing that
representative
Miner go ahead I'm sorry yeah thank you
m chair um the Declaration of purpose
probably was very close to being correct
a year ago but with the work of this
committee um uh it's no longer actually
uh I think correct um the purpose is is
not clear for example I'll read it says
that
um uh skip through there uh that uh the
solid Wass are not fully evaluated
through existing regulatory reviews um
and uh that's not taking into the
account the number of bills that this
committee has been put forward to the
house um and that uh with the moror
assuming that gets approved um that
whole Pro process actually is being
addressed by many bills here that I
don't think the author is familiar with
what's coming down okay that's one note
U which is important when when it's the
Declaration of purpose uh second thing I
thought was significant is that on page
17 it's numbered 17 um page 17 of 77 um
and at the
bottom it says an application for a
certificate from this new committee they
wish to create uh shall only be approved
or denied by the committee quote after
all other state agency approvals have
been obtained that means anyone
developing a a landfill here would have
to go through a whole permitting process
before they actually would assess it or
whether it's should be next to a park or
whatever that is you see what I mean uh
so that's kind of a double jeopardy and
uh clearly the bills that this committee
has been working on particularly the
ones looking at the net public benefit
we look at that first so that they don't
spend a huge amount of money and
resources trying to meet all the
environmental conditions if it's next to
a lake or for example or a a park so I
think that is a backwards process that I
think we've talked about quite a lot
here how the process should be so that
we don't have um uh private developers
spending significant amounts of money
and they oh sorry now we go through a
second round and I think uh the state
needs to work in partnership with the
private sector so that there's one clear
bite at the Apple and not after the fact
yeah okay I agree with that that's my
two major thing oh one last thing is the
um uh on the bill that we uh submitted
to the house for I think approval this
this week for next week it's um net
public benefit in here on page 18
halfway down it talks about evaluating
things such adverse things and positive
things but such as traffic noise and
odor but they never even even mentioned
the issue of groundwater pollution or P
so there's significant issues not here
that we've actually talked about that we
have in the legislation that we are
proposing so I think what we've worked
on actually uh is a stronger more
grounded approach than coming in after
the fact with this stuff thank you
representive
Penza uh thank you madam chair and I um
I agree with all those points that
representative were just made so I'm not
going to repeat them
um there's um there's a lot of wonderful
ideas that are that are in this I
thought it was 12 pages but it's I guess
it is 10 um page document and you know
some of them have already been brought
up but just how it starts off is um it
is Crystal Clear where we have um you
know right in the beginning of this you
know in the statement of per or
Declaration of purpose is we have um we
have a bill that's that we've spent a a
lot of time on that basically um is this
but more and um and takes out things
that you know um even from of course um
the department um we needed to take out
at that point so there's just you know
we have really in a sense three bills
that um could nicely um we take this 10
pages out and our three bills go in and
um it does so much of what she's doing
and more and the the council piece I I
think we've many of us have already said
that that that is um and after the fact
putting the cart before the horse does
doesn't make sense we would never want
anyone to go through an entire
permitting process to then be told you
know after whatever it may be five years
or something like that um in spending um
tens of thousands of dollars that okay
well um it just doesn't work um there's
also things in here that there's and I
have um a different copy of this at home
that I left at home because I just
didn't know if we were going to how much
we were going to spend time on it um
which is not lot a lot to go line by
line here but there's also um many
conflicts with with current within rules
and and statute and um current statute
and um that I or rsas that are on the
books um that make things not as um as
clean as well so um I I really think
that we have an opportunity here um and
I I greatly thank the governor for the
work that she's done in bringing um
these solid waste issues to the
Forefront uh there's have been a lot of
people for a long time that have been um
speaking about it so um I thank her and
commend her for that I think that we can
you know kind of be the answer to um to
or be the solution to a lot of her um
issues in here from legislation that we
have so um there's some stuff too in
regards with public hearings you know
these are um you know this these are all
in a sense um already
already law uh we have um
1622 that was passed that is now in
effect and has been for a few months now
um that's a fantastic uh amount um too
that has to do with public comment so so
many of these things are um are already
taken care of and that can be taken care
of through three pieces of legislation
that we have um right now so um I'm
hoping that that's what we can kind of
put forward together as our committee um
for that and it would be you know a
wonderful way for a lot of work to be
able to get implemented inside of hb2 so
thank you representative Bixby yeah I I
think um I uh also have uh similar
concerns to representative guers and
representative tenes uh another layer of
that is that it seems like you not only
is this uh would this committee be
operating after all of the permitting
process which is lengthly
inexpensive but it also seems like it is
creating an extra layer of bureaucracy
when we don't really need another layer
of bureaucracy what we need is to have
the correct requirements incorporated
into our existing structure and you know
if there's any and you know perhaps even
make that existing structure a little
bit more efficient but uh what we don't
want is to have another layer of red
tape that is just sort of stuck on top
of what's what we have already in terms
of requirements we want to make sure
that the existing require the we need to
improve the existing structure we don't
need to put another layer on top of it
sure I just wanted to comment on that
real thank you so much for bringing up
that piece um I would love um represent
ative ger to speak to this because um in
creating another level another Council
that isn't needed we have this Council
in place that was doing this kind of
work and when we noticed I mean we're
very vocal on it when we noticed those
gaps we brought them forward to the
previous administration and I I think
that that's really important because
when we realized that those gaps were
there they weren't filled immediately um
they still continued so so um let's get
one Council working efficiently in in in
at full capacity and representing the
public and all of that before we would
ever put any sort of other layer on top
of that that you know let's get that
worked I would love you to speak just to
that piece alone representative sure
representative ger thank you thank you
representative poten you I I believe
that we as a committee did a lot of work
to produce a really good bill in HB 2115
which is our public benefit Bill and
after long discussions with Dees that
consider both the impact on public
health and the environment but also
thinking about industry right and
Industry needing to have a Marketplace
that they understand and and is reliable
uh we had talked about the idea of a of
a site evaluation committee similar to
the one that exists that looked at the
Northern Pass project and the feeling
was that that was adding a layer of
bureaucracy that lengthened a process
and added a level of uncertainty that
isn't good for our communities or good
for Industries who are trying to open
new projects that what 25 doeses is it
allows us to use existing resources in a
much more streamlined way and by putting
it up front you are making it clear
right if you get a red light it's a red
light on a site if you get a green light
then you move ahead to looking at the
technical review of an application so uh
I I feel that we have provided something
that I'm glad to see hb2 incorporating
the idea really of of net public benefit
but I believe the bill that this
committee produced is a much more
efficient more streamlined process that
is people uh and uh so that uh we don't
so that it's we're not creating any
necessary uh
unnecessary um adversarial
relationships uh but uh that would also
give you know if there are things that
our bills are not covering that the
governor wants to make sure are in there
then that's also a room for nego some
negotiation which has to happen pretty
quickly I guess but uh but that that's
one way of
approaching uh approaching a piece of
policy sometimes
uh the uh hb2 is used by the Senate
particularly to stick us with pieces of
policy that they don't want to have a
thorough hearing in the house um that's
another thing that it it happens it's
not a perfect world um and uh Howard and
I spent a fair amount of time before he
was in a senate fighting fighting a
particular instance of that but uh but
um that's so I think in this case uh as
long as we're really transparent about
what what we're doing with all parties
involved I think that this could be a
very good way of of getting the getting
these pieces of policy that clearly um
are you
know in are in line with what the
governor's intent is here in terms of
making sure that the landfill process is
better I think that would that would be
a reasonable use of hb2 as long as we
don't mind the um lack of Purity in
process
yeah yeah
representa Scully thank you madam
chair it may have already been said but
I did also want to point out that this C
uh increases the cost for both business
and government itself uh there's a
$20,000 base filing fee plus some other
um add-ons in the trailer Bill yes in
the trailer bill yeah and then it also
um establishes another I guess full-time
position they talk about a salary for an
administrator right plus additional
costs and I think that in this year I
think the message has come down we're
going to be hit um seeing harder times
economically Statewide and we do not
want to grow government at all unless
it's absolutely necessary and given that
we do have hp215 which I think is a
great bill I I think we don't need this
and we don't need the cost or the
additional personel okay representative
Penza yeah thank you representative
Scully um yeah I agree
I I that was that's a two pieces that I
kind of forgot about that I have
highlighted at home as well um in
regards with the position in that too so
um it it's just if it was something that
was necessary that we you know that
there was a gap that that would be one
thing but there isn't a gap that that
it's just it's there's not a need there
um you know I don't want to grow and
have positions that are not necessary um
as well so that it's more important that
it's really not necessary so just spides
um us really needing to tighten the
budget and the pur strings because um of
kind of what we're facing here um in New
Hampshire I yeah it's just it's not even
necessary at this point for me for me it
just seems too that you know in in
putting this committee together and you
know who knows who's going to be on this
committee or who's going to get
appointed I don't know but um it just
seems to me that this committee is sort
of taking up or doing the work of what
es would normally do that's right and so
why would we want to either duplicate
efforts or um again put in that extra
layer of bureaucracy where it really is
not necessary representative
wheeler thank you madam chair just uh an
informational piece really kind of kind
of your question representative King
although I wanted to say it before um so
what we have here is the summary from
her pink sheet that came out to the
house a couple of weeks ago after she
gave her address which summarizes what
just came out about an hour ago which is
the full version of hb2 all 85 pages of
it so if you're really interested in
understanding what policy is in the
budget beyond the summary then you can
go online similar to how you would look
up any other Bill and then read hb2 line
by line the analysis of which has 102
different points in it so you
know well representative ger
thank you and I I also another piece of
215 which I think is really valuable
that is in this a proposed language has
to do with the independent third party
that would be uh paid for by the
applicant is not at all an exorbitant
fee for companies that make a lot of
money but I think it's really important
especially for potential host
communities because that report that
will be produced that Dees will use to
weigh potential benefits and potential
harms is I I think also really valuable
information for potential host
communities to have they don't have the
resources in many cases to hire
independent third parties to do that
work for them so this document says that
Dees May contract an independent third
party so it's in there but that's one of
the reasons why I think 215 is superior
because it is a streamlined process and
it requires the hiring of an independent
third party to do an assessment that
Dees would use and would also be
available to host communities
okay any other questions
comments okay so um what I'm going to do
is uh I am well I guess I I will
communicate um with chairman Wier uh
regarding our consensus on um striking
this piece out and instead including in
the language for hp215 HB 171 and H
707 and um at the same time we need I
I'll talk with him and see where we
might be able to get together with um
the governor or some folks from the
governor's office to discuss that
strategy and um and see where we are
with that is that okay all right good
enough okay well thank you for taking
the time I know it was a lengthy
document um
and uh there's you know certainly a lot
a lot to look at I appreciate that
you've taken the time to look at it and
afford the community uh the committee
with your um with your opinions on each
of that and I think we all pretty much
agree um on on how that should be
handled so thank you
all with
that I'm going to hand over the gavl
to my esteemed
colleague I am um going
to remove myself from my
chair and we can move on to the next
order of
business pink cards
here whatever you like
I need to get a cop
theill uh good I get that P
sure the there's one over there I just I
have one in my
see C see
I thought there'd be some more
okay
so yeah um
CH best
s
okay
okay e
it's going to be
first second
start good afternoon I open uh our
hearing on HB 616 FN and I'd like to
recognize uh representative Judy Aaron
to introduce the
Bill thank you Mr
chair um for the record my name is
representative Judy Aaron I represent
the towns of aworth Goan langon lemster
and Washington which is Sullivan County
District
4 good afternoon to you all I'm
introducing this bill HB 616 relative to
the confiscation of animals from persons
suspected or charged with abuse of
animals this bill came about after a
horrible animal seizure incident
happened this past April in Lee New
Hampshire the details of this event will
be explained in subsequent testimony but
I would like to take this is time to go
through the parts of this bill which
seek to solve the problems which
occurred with this kind of animal
seizure we need to make sure that when
it comes to property seizure that due
process is followed and that animals and
their owners are treated properly and I
hope you all have a copy of the bill in
front of you because I'm going to go
through
it the language
changes to RSA 644 col 8 were developed
with New Hampshire Farm Bureau the New
Hampshire Department of Agriculture UNH
extension and other concerned parties
after this event took place in Lee New
Hampshire they felt that further
language to existing statutes were
needed to clarify procedures surrounding
animal cruelty reporting and seizure and
indicate who should or should not be
involved in the
process first off on page one lines 3 to
six
we want to make sure that an
investigating officer is advised by
someone from the state veterinarian's
office or a designated veterinarian that
their office
recommends we've already seen with
another bill which was heard in our
committee that law enforcement needs
advice in these situations and we'd like
to make sure that the right people are
giving advice we also want to make
certain that no animals may be
confiscated without a person legally
charged in this case in Lee
there were no charges made no
convictions made and no due process
regarding seizure of animals and yet a
person's animals were taken away some
were euthanized some were adopted out
and no one seems to know what happens to
the remaining
ones this happened mostly because the
owner was made to sign a document under
duress without a clear understanding
about what was being signed in any event
the law should be quite clear about when
animals can be taken away and by whom
the owner of the animal should also know
exactly what they are being charged
with there is a um in the next section
lines nine and 10 there is a change that
needs to be made here because of a
drafting
error um it says here the person charged
shall be made aware of this petition and
writing by the arresting officer when it
we're already talking about the person
charged under the section can petition
the court to seek an examination of the
Animals by a veterinarian licensed under
RSA
332 uh hyen B and so what this next line
should say is that the person charge
shall be made aware of the ability to
make this
petition because if there if the person
charge shall be made aware of the
petition I mean they're already making
the petition they don't need to be aware
of it so but they need to know that they
have the ability to make this petition
and they should be getting that in
writing from the arresting
officer so that's a change that needs to
be made because of a drafting
error in lines uh 11 through
17 we're adding a new subparagraph that
states that prior to any conviction of
abuse or neglect no confiscated animal
can be altered without the notorized um
authorization of the
owner they the animals can't be altered
examples being spayed neutered or
euthanized in the case in Lee animals
were taken away that were already being
treated for illnesses and under a
veterinarian's care and some were simply
euthanized after being
taken there were also animals that were
castrated this should simply not happen
additionally in this section we are
specifically making it clear that prior
to a conviction of abuse or negle
no animal should be used to solicit
donations or be used to fundraise by any
individual or
organization these unfortunate incidents
should not be used for purposeful
purposeful gain by anyone especially if
a case has not been brought to a court
of law and
adjudicated in lines 20 to
21 we want to specify that only law
enforcement or an animal control officer
can take custody of animal animals and
animals cannot be taken into temporary
protective custody unless the owner or
caretaker is not present or if there is
a clear and eminent danger to the
animal's Health animal seizure should
not should be a matter between law
enforcement and the owner of the animals
no other entity should be
involved on page two in lines 5 to
7 we want to make sure that an owner of
an an animal taken into protective
custody has the right to have their
animal examined by a veterinarian of his
or her choice at the expense of the
owner we want to make sure that the
veterinarian examining the animals in
question is familiar with the animals in
question aside from the fact that we
shouldn't have a dog or a cat
veterinarian making assessments on
animals they are unfamiliar with like
livestock goats horses Etc but we also
want to make sure that if the animal is
already being treated for an illness
that the veterinarian that is involved
in that treatment should be the one
that's
involved as part of some statute
housekeeping we want to eliminate lines
12 to 26 on page two as we do not
currently do harness or live dog racing
in our state anymore so that part of
this uh current statute just needs to be
stricken in lines 27 to
29 on page two we want to ensure that
when lactating animals are confiscated
that there is proof that the facility
that they are going to will provide
proper care and Facilities to
accommodate adults and their offspring
we cannot allow animals to be taken away
and euthanize because there's not proper
milking facilities available or that
proper care is not available for
lactating female and its
babies I would say too that we should
probably add here and believe that that
was also a drafting error where
something was left out that in a case of
confiscation mothers should not be
separated from their babies and vice
versa for this case in Lee I was told
that lactating females were taken away
and were euthanized because there were
no people to milk them this is very
concerning lines
30-34 ensures that a person who made the
complaint or report should not take part
in or be present during the
investigation also the person's taking
possession of any animal seized as a
result of a complaint may not take part
or be present during the investigation
into the complaint we do not want the
person making the complaint or the
person receiving the animals as a result
of the complaint to be part of the
investigation as they have a biased
interest and they may have something to
gain in the removal or possession of the
animal in question
question again the only people that
should be part of the investigation is
the animals owner law enforcement and a
qualified veterinarian who can properly
assess what is going
on in lines 35 to 36 on page two and
lines one to two on page three it says
simply that if animals are confiscated
or taken into protective custody without
the owner being charged with a crime
then that is considered theft by
unauthorized taking
on page three lines 3 to 7 we clarify
that any veterinarian or individual
requested to provide assistance by law
enforcement is protected and held
harmless for criminal or civil
liability on lines 21 to 23 on page
three we also add that no livestock
shall be confiscated or taken into
protective custody without the
recommendation of the state V Arian or
their
design these are all very important
changes to the statutes and they serve
to clarify what should and should not
happen in the event of a report of
abuse there was a lot that went wrong in
the Lee
case these charges uh these changes to
the current law will help make sure that
due process is followed and that both
people's rights and animals welfare is
protected
and I'd be happy to take any
questions um but um I would also uh say
that there are people who are here today
who will give you more insight into why
these changes are
necessary um and I also have written a
copy of my
testimony thank you for your testimony
and for introducing this Bill uh are
there any
questions representative King thank you
Mr chair um on page I guess it's
considered one it's the back of the
first page on lines 15 to 17 thank you
for introducing the bill by the way and
thank you for taking questions um it
says um and you you touched on this um
nor nor shall such animal or animals be
used in any manner to solit solicit
donations or to fundraise by any
individual or organization
and I'm just wondering sometimes when
the state comes down on an
individual um people will create like a
GoFundMe for their legal defense or
something like that is that what you had
in mind or can you just give me some
examples of of what what this really is
all about because it just seems weird
that a person wouldn't be able to like
kind of crowdfund a legal defense or
something what is that all about well
um there's been many instances where um
in situations of um animal seizures or
um reports of animal abuse that there
are
organizations um specifically some of
the animal rights
organizations that will put out some
sort of press release um I have one
specifically
here from the New Hampshire SPCA
that came out and reported this whole
incident in Lee New Hampshire and all
over it is um you know we're asking for
the community's assistance and caring
for these animals this is a fundraising
mechanism and I don't believe that in
these unfortunate inst instance
instances whether they're legitimate uh
reports or they're not legitimate
reports that there should be
organizations that are profiting from
this um and you know they they not only
profit from uh you know a press release
that says oh look at all the great work
that we're
doing but they're also profiting off
adopting out the animals um and and I
think that um you know that again this
is these are unfortunate incidences and
I don't believe that people should
profit off them follow up yes okay so um
thank you for the clarification um
so I see what you're saying as far
as like institutions or organizations
but what I mean would it in your opinion
would this also preclude like a
crowdfunding for a defense of the people
whose animals have been taken because it
seems like this is a a a knife that cuts
both ways a little bit and I'm just
wondering if if your intention is that
it would also hit somebody who's trying
to crowd crowdfund a defense and then
also just just on top of that I don't
know it's just it's in subsection 8
there and it's there's like two
different topics really being discussed
in sub I mean there's only four lines
but the two really I don't think go
together I feel like it should be its
own thing I don't know just yeah that
you know that's uh certainly I I know
this bill is going to have some
amendments put into it and that's
certainly something that we C we as a
committee can discuss uh and how to uh
break that apart um and probably make it
more specific in
nature representative
Penza thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking my question I have I have a few
um I'm not you know well versed in the
um in this legislation or you know um
this cruelty to animals section of of
current statute so
um right
now due process and all of these things
are extremely important I I you know I
commend you for putting this forward
especially I'm familiar with the
situation that took place in Lee because
I'm in straford County
um I guess my question is is
are where where we're in you know
talking in bold here these things are um
they're not currently in statute so are
they not happening um they're just
complete gaps are not taking place are
some people like may be doing it but
others aren't do you know what I'm
saying okay yeah that's why we want to
clarify so just trying to keep it
consistent yes sir okay and um in
regards with the veterinarian piece so
if right now someone confiscates an
animal and they are under that care um
are are we just um ignoring their
current their current doctor in a sense
or like I don't in some instances I
believe that's true and that's why I
wanted to make that clear in statute um
that there is the ability to have a
veterinarian who's currently caring for
those animals be
involved
um yep I'm sorry thank
you yes definitely a quick followup um
in regards with the um the person being
charged being made uh made aware of the
petition in writing how would that can
you explain to me in a perfect world um
CU I know there's probably going to be
some work that needs to be done a little
bit on the bill like what proc how do
how what process works like that like
give me kind of like from the time of
you know a charge or an arrest or
whatever like how how does someone make
sure that they get their paperwork and
all of that kind of stuff can you so I I
would say that a person if a person is
charged under this ction so they can
petition the court to seek an
examination of the Animals by a
veterinarian licensed under
332b of his or her choice at the expense
of the person charged they may not know
that they can do that and that's why we
need to specify that the person when
they are charged with abuse or neglect
they should be told by the arresting
officer that they have the ability to
make this
petition because they might not they
most people wouldn't even know and so
they would think that um well whoever
the veterinarian is that showed up to
assess the
situation um you
know might be all well and good but they
might want to have their own
veterinarian to come and um and say you
know what happened or what didn't happen
or the condition of the animal to report
on that perfect thank
you uh representative King
thank you again Mr chair um another
question you're talking about the one
section where it says that if an animal
is seized and it can't be taken care of
by the state because maybe they don't
have the facilities or the setup you
can't just euthanize the
animal and I'm curious um what then you
know cuz like when it comes to like
children oftentimes when children are
taken from parents they're given to
grandparents they're given to
uncles or somebody close in the family
they're given to another person that
doesn't work for the State but has the
capability of helping to raise the child
while there's some litigation going on
and I'm wondering if you imagine the
idea of let's say some animals are taken
instead of the state killing them and
instead of the state always having the
ability to take care of all different
animals they find another farmer that
does take care of those specific animals
and and if the farmer is willing to take
them for the time being I'm just trying
to wrap my head around what would happen
if they don't kill the animals and the
state doesn't have the ability to take
care of them what what then do you do
well I think they would they would be
able to um be able to find a place that
would take care of them or they could
leave them U you know at the farm that
they're at or with a nearby farmer or
whoever there I'm sure that they would
be able to find a place uh where they
would be able to be taken care of
properly I mean that's part of the part
of the
seizure represent Scag thank thank you
Mr chair um regarding the cost of care
of the animals uh is that borne by the
state uh and if somebody petitioned the
court and they were found not guilty of
animal
cruy um again it seems like they should
not be charged for the cost of that and
on the other hand if they were guilty of
animal cruelty would it be reasonable
for the state to charge them for the
cost of care and cre the animal I
believe with regarding cost of care
issues the best person to answer that
question would be our Commissioner of
Agriculture and uh and I know we did um
we did dispense with a bill this uh this
morning having to do with cost of care
so that's an issue too that may uh may
have some bearing with this bill as we
work through the amendment
process thank
you uh yes represent
Penza thank you Mr chair I know we want
to get through this because there's a
lot of other people I'm not I'm not
rushing I just I just want to make sure
that I get everyone who wants to have a
question I want to go back just a little
bit to um the question the line of
questioning that representative King had
in regards with um
this H I don't know um what do you call
it um profiting on um you know prior to
a conviction
[Music]
um I
just I think it I I think it makes sense
to be in there I just I wonder know how
we would
um
uh police that like I I just you know
what I mean like and I I have a hard
time for example um people like to take
matters in their own hands and they get
upset about you know abuse especially um
there was a case um that had to do with
great danes um in the state and um I
remember receiving a social media post
um that was um you know in a sense kind
of threatening to the PE those people
and um you know take action now you know
shut these people down type of thing and
um so I
just like what would you first see as
like how like who would that then get
reported to the same kind of like in the
same um space as um the animal cruelty
folks to say okay there's you know
there's a group over here that's um
nobody's been convicted yet and they
need to um they're trying to rile it up
whether it be you know not just just
fundraising but there's a lot of other
stuff that happens too as well so I just
don't know how that would work I want to
just kind of understand well I think
that you know um those kind of social
media
pieces
um I guess we we we would have some
folks who would be involved in the in
the situation who would um be aware of
some of those fun raising efforts going
on and perhaps report it I mean I don't
know I mean that's something I think
that we have to work through um and
clarify yeah so there could just be like
a reporting mechanism you know like you
make a report to the AG we could you
could make a report to whatever the
investigating entity for this to say Hey
you know this person's doing that or
whatever they should probably you know
you should probably nip that in the bud
type of thing I think you know the the
wording itself I mean we were just very
concerned that there were people who
were profiting off of these incidences
and we don't believe that people or
organizations should profit off of these
things that happen yeah I agree thank
you are there any other questions for
representative
Aaron thank you representative Aon you
and next I'd like to call uh
commissioner Shan Jasper
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I am Sean Jasper commissioner
of the Department of Agriculture markets
and food I was involved in the early
drafting of this legislation um but not
to the end um I think this is a very
important piece of
legislation um but I do have some some
concerns about some of the the Drafting
and I do intend to be here um tomorrow
your work session and hopefully might be
able to uh to help there because I do
have to get to London der for previous
engagement on a AGR tourism issue at an
apple orchard for three o'clock so um on
Roman
4 uh A1 line six the first
page while I've believe very much that
there should be someone there the state
veterinarian or is design and and first
of all I want to say the intent was not
that the design necessarily be a
veterinarian because that's going to
really limit the ability would be
somebody who had been chosen in advance
um we had been talking about working
with Farm Bureau to develop a list of
people who might be able to provide
expertise and that's part of the issue
is why um the indemnification is in
there but I do believe there should be
an exception and I I would just say
except when the officer believes that
the animals life is an immediate danger
and remember there's already a court
order in place for these seizures
they've already gone there and 247 365
days a year you're not always going to
be able to get the veterinarian or
design and if it's obvious that there's
an immediate danger there needs to be an
exception so I would suggest you add
that uh in
6648 Roman 4
A2 it currently allows for the owner to
petition the court we've talked about
that the and that's when charged but if
you go to the protective custody it's
just an automatic and it doesn't even
say when they're charged now obviously
if if they show up and they get their
animals back they're not going to need
to do that but the standard should not
be different and I don't I wouldn't care
whether it's one or the other whether
they need a court order or they just
have the right to do it but for the one
which is a more serious they have to go
through the court and for the other it's
not automatic so would suggest that that
be
standardized um page two lines
36 and Page Three L uh page two line 36
page three line one to two negates
protective custody by making any such
theft um unauthorized theft by
unauthorized taking I think that's got
to be some sort of a
mistake but right the now the way it's
written right at the the bottom of the
page uh um it does State quite clearly
to me that anytime you use protective
custody then it's theft by unauthorized
taking the unauthorized taking uh or
excuse me the protective custody is a
section that I think has led to the
problem particularly in Lee because no
charges were filed that was only
intended to be when no one was there and
the animals were in immediate danger of
not being fed watered um not that
somebody was there and they've decided
to take them into protective custody so
the the language clarifying that is very
important um and there does need to be
the ability of it and you'd say well why
might you need to use that all right
you'd been in an automobile accident had
a heart attack something happened you're
unconscious you're in the hospital you
have nobody to take care of your animals
and no way of contacting anybody and
your neighbors say Hey you know Sean's
not home and his animals are starving to
death
there needs to be a mechanism for those
animals to be taken into protected
custody that's why this section in my uh
my opinion is so important to have but
also there as a result charges could
still be uh leveled levied um but it's
not necessarily an abuse or neglect case
on purpose so there is some U there are
some circumstances that make that
necessary to have in there
and again on page um page three lines 20
to 23 does not provide for emergency
action by the police police um and I
don't I'm not sure that that even needs
to be in there because when it rises to
a case of protective
custody then the individual being
charged falls back to the the first
instance of them being able to uh be
notified because charges would be filed
they'd be notified that they could have
an a veterinarian inspect the animals so
overall it's a very good bill I think
there are our problems um that need to
be addressed and I look forward to being
able to work with the committee on on
that I'll be glad to take any any
questions at this time representative
Penza thank you Mr chair I just have two
questions pretty quick it was based upon
the points that you made so that would
be page two um
lines like 35 36 that continue to the
next page and then the ones that you
just mentioned on page three um
2021-22 so are you saying that
um that's just written wrong the
confiscation of an animal without the
charging of the owner under paragraph um
four the determination that the animals
Animal should be taken into temporary
protective custody under this paragraph
shall be theft by unauthorized taking
under RSA are you just saying that that
that's um personally I don't believe
that that belongs there at all because
if you're taking into protective custody
they're leaving you a note telling you
where you can go get your animal back
you can get it back unless charges a
file I do think that perhaps there
should be a further um clarification in
that area and I would say on U page two
lines 25 26 mhm it probably should be
clear that the animals shall be returned
unless charges are
filed and right now it says the
procedure to have the animal returned
and any other relevant information that
sort of leaves it open-ended perhaps to
the average person going well what's the
procedure I have to go through with this
case the only procedure should be where
do you get them and when can you get
them but I but I just I think it would
help if it clarified that they will get
them back unless the police have decided
to file
charges um
followup yes
okay okay I think that's great um would
you be okay with it I think that the
whole point of that being in there is
just more of a uh enforcement statement
so um so let's say if it is put up near
where on page two line um
you know about getting them back and all
of that that do do you mind it just
basically saying that of course you know
any animals um that were taken
underneath you know RSA 63
6373 Blah Blah Blah by any means would
be considered that theft by unauthorized
taking just to have that statement in
there as I don't I don't understand the
circumstances in which you could take an
animal into protective custody oh and
then say but that was theft oh I see I I
don't I I think those so that would have
to be in a different section of the bill
I don't think that I don't think there
are any circumstances where if it's true
the animal was taken into protective
custody then it was returned how could
you then say it was theft by
unauthorized taking because it was taken
in to protect the C it was taken similar
to somebody who's taken off the street
for being intoxicated they're not
charged they sober up the police let
them go without charges that's the
purpose of protective custody to protect
the animal and I think other than when
an owner is just being negligent and not
feeding watering the animal taking care
of them they're not around they need to
be taken but ultimately charges need to
be done need to be filed right uh I'm
just going to take a a little bit of a u
make a little uh question about that
part but so I believe that the intent in
that uh section was that uh it would be
uh taking animals is acceptable if there
is a charge taking animals is acceptable
if it's protective custody if neither of
those cases is the is
uh is it applies then it would be theft
and uh so I I do you see that that that
the way it's currently expressed doesn't
Express that clearly I think it it
doesn't but um I I do think that e
covers both you know just the first part
of that the confiscation of an animal
without the charging of the owner under
paragraph five uh
four you
know shall be theft by unauthorized
taking and I think this gets back to the
Lee case where the owner was not charged
and everyone seemed to think that they
the police were used using the
protective custody which I think even
the police may have thought they were
using but it it should not have applied
and that's why this needs to be
clarified and that led to the problem if
you clar clarify that I don't think
you're going to end up in the same
situation ever again thank you I I think
that what we're getting we're we're
getting into a sort of a redrafting mode
here which I don't think we need to be
doing in a hearing so let's let's move
move on representative
Scully thank you Mr chair c could you
please briefly Explain how how um you
handle the costs that are sure so
anytime animals are seized and only when
they're seized not when they're taken
into protective custody and not when
they are surrendered because often times
what happens is the police come in and
will say you're going to if you don't
surrender your animals or some number of
them you will be charged so if they
surrender them then that is off the cost
of care fund but when the police sees
the animals
uh the cost of care fund is responsible
for the care the reasonable care of
those animals until the court case is
adjudicated and there are just to
clarify there are times too when they
may surrender a certain number of
animals and another number of animals
may be
seized and they're still charged but the
number of animals may be reduced so it's
it gets very complicated at times
followup yes thank you um if a
if somebody's convicted of animal
cruelty does the state go after them to
recover Char uh
costes in theory yes so far I haven't
seen any money come back into the fund U
most of the time those people don't have
any money that we can collect but that
is the theory uh and it is in in the
cost of care statute that if they're
convicted they would be responsible to
reimburse the fund thank
you are there any more questions for the
commissioner
thank
you thank you for sharing your expertise
you are welcome and I will be here
tomorrow at your disposal disposal you
know I've had a long weekend as I've
told Finance I've been trying to get my
ducks in a row but I found that they're
all over the pond right now and that
continues
today okay next I'd like to hear from
Donna Lee Woods of Lee
oh so if you can introduce yourself with
your name and your commun the community
you're from uh Donna Lee Woods Lee New
Hampshire thank you
hick Nut
Farm we're passing some info
out everybody should get one okay could
you bring the microphone a little a
little bit closer to
you everybody gets
one okay
uh whenever you want to start say what
please you can start whenever you want
okay um hick Nut Farm was formed in in
2000 and is a state registered and
inspected goat milk dairy specializing
in goat milk firm cheeses yo goat GT
fudge and soap we have five breeds of
dairy goats the alpines the over Hosley
sarin Nubians and the toggenburgs each
breed has its characteristic
confirmation milk quality and
quantity when we started the farm we
wanted people to come and visit us our
farm has always been an open Farm
over the years we have hosted many Tours
School children tours birthday parties
Etc it was important to us to invite
people to learn about goats about
farming and the quality of
food on April 29th a woman
came and walked all over remember it's
an open Farm she sent me a scathing
email about our farm I emailed her back
and invited her to take a tour with me
so we could just discuss her concerns
she did not respond to me and contacted
the sbca
instead on May 1st an inspector and
Associate showed up and asked to look
around I said of course they did and
left then on May 10th the inspector and
one of their vets showed up with a
police chief and many people and
vehicles I was completely knocked off
guard I couldn't think of or comprehend
what was going on the police said I had
to sign a search warrant if I didn't he
would arrest
me they proceeded to move my goats all
around and said that I had to kill five
ladies we call our female goats ladies
they were here as grandmas they were our
oldest to our kids kids being the baby
goats there was nothing wrong with them
except age the vet wanted to take one of
our black kids little baby goat he was
perfect and would follow me all around I
asked why she said he had a thin
neck also they wanted to take a
month-old white kid that was very thin I
asked them not to take him as I had him
on a special milk diet of goat milk
colostrum and goat milk replacer he was
born thin and was doing well they said
they knew what they were doing they said
I had until May
24th to do their
recommendations they showed up May
21st in the report the vet said that the
goats were walking around on their knees
probably
CAE if it were CAE which causes lame and
sore knees they would not be walking
around on
them CAE is a caprine arthritic in
incilius and it is commonly thought of
being in probably 20% of all
goats and there are two schools of
thought about that is to whether you
euthanize them once you have them tested
as little kids or you raise them up now
if a goat's in pain a goat's going to
grind its teeth and you know you've got
a problem and then you make a
decision usually with a CAE goat they
may not show any
um issues until they're 8 years old
that's the that's with a Dr George our
vet that's what we practice that we do
with the 8-year-old goats on May 24th
1st I had just finished having a tour
with 20 kindergarten kids and Was
preparing for the next group of kids
when I looked up and there was the SPCA
with cars many people police and horse
trailer I told her I had a tour and she
said cancel it
they proceeded to take 52 goats now at
this point will be 54 they've taken the
goats were screaming the police would
not let me near them to comfort them
saying I would tamper with evidence he
pulled on my clothes sprained my wrist
would not leave me alone he stayed one
foot from me I kept pleading with him to
stop and he would not I have never
experienced such brutality in my life I
was just scared I was so scared I could
hardly breathe as I said the goats were
scared and screaming they had locked the
goats in a small stall for a man
handling them tugging
them to the trailer we had we have 11
stalls for the ladies to choose where
they want to spend time which is about
2100 Square ft of open stall space
also we practice winter pack stall
treatment which means that we allow the
bedding of fresh hay to build up to two
or so feet every winter we start
building this winter pack in August so
by the time we have bit bitter cold
weather the pack will be a couple of
feet thick in the spring they are
cleaned out to the gravel this year our
skid steer was being repaired and we had
started to clean a stall with a
wheelbarrow that is the stall the
inspectors chose to use it was also Al a
93 day and with all their weight on the
winter pack and all the goats the odor
was strong they were asked to move by
one of our farm team and they ignored
her one of our ladies a milka was being
hauled up to the trailer by having her
front legs pulled and then another
person picked up her back legs they
would not let her walk she was one of 10
milkers that they took I asked what they
were going to do with the milk they said
they have no one to milk so they let
these sweet ladies dry up in pain and
get
mastitis they took my sarn and buck that
I had just
bought I had a mom that was in the
throws of kidding and she was fighting
ketosis I had her on a molasses in water
every hour schedule they took her I
asked them not to touch her she was
resting and beginning to turn around
another another lady was fighting dry
scaly skin and was getting zinc
treatment zinc zinc Bolis they took her
I I asked them not to touch
her they took moms without kids they
took kids without moms they took the
five grandmas we have six large water
troughs that are filled every day there
are three in the lower barn and three in
the upper Barn so water is accessible at
all times we had a lady born with bent
legs we built her a cradle with PVC pipe
in Wheels she didn't like it so she
walked around on her knees one of the
inspectors saw a goat that we had put
down the day before because she was in
pain when we put a goat down we put them
way down back in a shallow grave for the
coyotes to eat they do a great job the
bones are then buried in the compost
piles to decompose nothing is wasted on
May 22nd the white goat was going into K
the the white goat that was going into
ketosis was not doing well and the
inspector called me not emailed me and
wanted to call Dr George who knows goats
he's excellent with goats but I had to
give approval I said yes the inspector
told me to email that to him and he gave
me the words to use I did the next
morning I woke up and thought what did I
just do he told me to write words that
turned all my goats over to them I
emailed him and said I take it back he
never responded I was so scared frozen
invulnerable neither the sbca nor the
police would respond to me the sbca took
54 goats killed 22 and offered the rest
back to me for
$40,000 they said I could buy the son
and buck back for
$400 but I had to sign a paper that
would give them full access to my farm
whenever they wanted and do whatever
they
wanted they gave me a list of 25 goats
that were me recommended to be treated
either by a vet or have their Hooves
trimmed
how did they end up taking 52 without
any probable cause now as far as the
goats hoofs in the winter time we tend
not to trim this trim them as much as we
would in the summertime I like to call
it their ski boots because they the
Hooves get thick and when they get thick
it gives them a little cushion from the
cold from the snow and the the
ground they left 30 goats why didn't
they take all of my goats if they were
in such D
circumstances on June 14th we have a med
we had a mediation at the farm it lasted
a few hours with no mediation done the
sbca would not budge after the sbca
price release we got threats one in
particular was a threat to spray paint
our cars we were scared so I called the
police they sent a young cop and he said
there wasn't anything they could do and
he left
also at the end the sbca asked for money
to pay for the care and
food any questions would you be willing
to take questions absolutely okay uh are
there any questions from the committee
uh representative
wheeler thank you Mr chair I I don't
have a question for you I'm
just sorry that you had to go what you
had to go through thank you it's just
horrible they come in like gapo they
treat you like you're some kind of not
an I mean just just yeah just really
saddened to hear this story and
passionate in getting something done to
make sure that this never happens again
thank you for being here thank you okay
uh I'd just like to make a note that um
this is a fairly charged topic we need
to be very careful to uh make sure that
we are respectful of everyone in the
room and that we do not ascribe motive
to people uh and uh so what we need to
what we're looking for is uh the full
facts of the case and uh which is I I
don't want to put a damper on anyone
Express you know uh presenting any of
their evidence but I want to make sure
that it is done in a very respectful way
okay uh so I believe that representative
King was next and then uh representative
minor and representative uh okay so
thank you Mr chair um thank you for your
testimony and for taking questions you
said there was originally a lady who
visited your farm she complained and
then uh sometime later another person
came was that from the SPCA and you she
asked to look around and you said of
course or was that from some other
organization the lady came walk the farm
when I wasn't there because it's an open
Farm um and then the sbca showed up okay
and and and they asked to look it was
the inspector and a person with him I
don't know who it was um do you believe
that in the future if an spaca person
shows up you would deny them access to
your farm or do it's a closed Farm now
it's a closed Farm now yeah so are you
not letting anybody from the public
visit either okay okay unless I'm there
and take them on a tour yep okay thank
you thank you Mr chair this is more of
aate then there a question I've known uh
Don and Lee for many many years uh both
participating in uh farma markets you I
have and again I don't know if this is
proper or not but I know Donna Lee I
know how she takes care of her animals
and um this this is a terrible
thing okay uh representative
gerana thank you Mr chair and thank you
Miss Woods for taking my question sorry
to hear everything that you've been
through thank you for being here today
could you tell us a little bit I'm
reading through some of the documents
you shared with us here uh specifically
the probable cause statement and could
you uh tell us about your interaction
with the vet who who came to the farm
because I understand one of the things
we're trying to do in this bill is to
make sure that veterinarians with the
applicable expertise are the people who
are who are doing the assessment so
could you tell us about your interaction
with the veterinarian who came out and
took a look at your goats the first um
vet was a cat doctor and and she a
pleasant lady um but taking a goat with
a thin
neck may I ask is that miss is that Dr
Boer she was okay thank you very much
yeah and but can you say more about how
your this interaction between because
it's quite detailed in here but if you
could say more from your perspective
about your interaction with the the vet
throughout the course of this
investigation um well I think there were
there was vet came that came to the
second at the second time when they took
all the goats there was so many people
there so much stuff I'm I can't even
begin to tell you how many people were
there and it was just you know it even
now I hear the goat screaming at night
time I just can't get over that so I'm
really not clear about all that I know
that Dr Boer came she took two of the
little kids and then there was another
vet I think
that um came the next time where they
took the other 52 goats and I don't know
who it is does it say it in there who
the second vet
was I haven't gotten that far yet trying
to read through it but thank you very
much for your answer representative
Pensa thank you Mr chair and um thank
you for taking my question and for being
here um I know how hard it is um with
stories like these my question is I want
to know what's going on like right now
like who is being held accountable um
for all of these things that took place
do you one do you have a lawyer is there
an active lawsuit against the state or
the sbca I like I want to know where are
we at like there needs to be some
justice in this situation and I want to
know if the if the
uh if the wheels of just are are
rolling
yes thank
you are they rolling
strong okay thank
you okay are there any other more are
there yes representative
Freeman thank you m Mr chair and thank
you so much for coming in front of us I
know this must be very difficult to keep
reliving this um do you and have you
looked at the bill I'm sure you have
have you looked at this bill that's
being
presented yes okay so do you believe
that this bill if it had been in place
in 2000 when that had occurred on your
farm that this bill would have prevented
all of that from
happening one of the things that I'm
concerned about is is um livestock
versus domestic
animals it has got to be
clear um
goats are sweet sweet
animals they're very
friendly and very trusting if they're
brought up that
way um and if somebody comes in and
starts manhandling them they go they go
whacky in their heads they just you know
it's pitiful it's a pitiful
thing so I think that that has really
got to be
clarified and the Farms have got to know
somehow the farmers have got to know
that they do have I didn't know you that
there is protection for us as farmers of
of
livestock yes thank you so a a bill a
bill like this that would be cified into
law would definitely be helpful for
Farmers as far as their rights with
their farm animals and their domestic
animals as well do you agree with that
yes but they've got to know
it representative H Haskins thank you Mr
chair and thank you madam for coming to
testify we appreciate you thank you do
you know whether it was the stratum
Office of the SPCA that came to your
farm do you know if the individuals that
were involved are still do you happen to
know in their employe yes thank you
are there any other
questions thank you very much for coming
thank
you next uh Lisa Dennison from the
nhspca good afternoon thank you for
having us
today um
as you said it's a very charged case and
there's a lot of information that's
shared and there's a lot of information
that's not shared I I'll just say that
to
start um hopefully some of what I share
with you today will clarify some of that
information and I'm happy to answer
questions when you know at the end I
also have other staff members here today
testifying as
well on behalf of the board and the
staff of the New Hampshire espca I want
to submit testimony in opposition to
House Bill 616
as the oldest and largest Humane Society
in the state of New Hampshire we are in
stratum New Hampshire um we were founded
in 1872 we take great pride in caring
for more than 3,800 animals each year
both large and small for more than 150
years we've been protecting beasts of
Burden those large animals named in our
first agents report in
1874 we have been protecting horses over
burdened starved and left suffering in
other words we have a long history of
protecting animals in the 31 years that
I've been the executive director at the
New Hampshire
SPCA I've had four Humane agents
employed three of them retired police
officers very well versed in the law two
of them remain on our staff today and
you'll hear from them
later this past year we received more
than
681 complaints of animal cruelty
involving more than
animals of these 191 far more than the
50 cited in the financial um
impact 191 cases involved 583 animals
that were farm animals and equines
subsequently 67 were
surrendered almost 600 only 67
surrendered and 66 were
seized when when we receive calls
they're investigated by local animal
control local police departments and
ourselves the goal is
education guidelines and resources when
needed and only protection in emergent
situations we believe strongly that
people are truly trying to do their best
sadly however sometimes individuals are
no longer capable of providing the care
and well-meaning Friends May offer
advice but they're unable to change
circumstances though cases with live EV
evidence are supposed to take precedence
on the court system they often take
months if not years to resolve
themselves boarding and care costs when
animals are in protective custody Mount
up quickly and become insurmountable to
those charged with animal cruelty only a
few weeks ago we finally settled a case
of 39 animals being taken after 18
months so one of the things that was
spoken about earlier is fundraising and
though we do press releases because the
media hears the police reports they come
they call us they ask they want to come
see the animals and yes we tell them
that they can give funding to this uh
the cost of not I'm getting cost of care
to our first aid fund for
animals we can go for years before we
receive any funding somebody's got to
pay the vet bills the legal fees the
care the boarding the Staffing and when
people say CU I had a conversation with
a chief the other day and he said you
know you're able to raise funding I said
yes but I can't repair the injury to my
Vette Tech who was mauled by one of the
German Shepherds who's now left the
industry I can't keep 36 German
Shepherds sane in our building for two
years while this goes through the court
cases it's very difficult The Compassion
fatigue is
real this past year we removed six
horses from a facility the family
members who lived across the country
were unaware that the owner now living
with
dementia we did not charge her with
cruelty and I think that's really
important to understand our goal is not
to V you know to charge people every
time when it's unintentional many times
most of the time most of the time it's
neglect it is not cruelty people aren't
actively inflicting harm but they're neg
leful it's a it's a little bit like the
frog in the in the pot of
water charging would have been
cruel in another case this case that
we're talking about earlier where the 54
goats were removed we had two USDA
licensed
veterinarians who were accredited for
livestock they were not cat vets though
they may work with cats as well and the
one Dr Boer who was refer earlier for
more than seven years was the lead vet
in the California state fairs she was
very well versed in farm
animals the State Vet was there well the
State Vet wasn't but two of their
technicians was there when they when we
arrived and they said oh you've got two
vets here we don't need to be here and
they left we would have loved for them
to have
stayed yes 18 animals were euthanized
immediately another died on the way to
to the vet's
practice it was a very dire situation
though professional colleagues had Ed a
reduction in the herd and euthanizing
for those in pain sooner well-meaning
was not enough and by the way no animals
are castrated no cats and dogs are
spayed and neuters when animals are in
protective custody when I've testified
in the past they've said somebody came
up and they said you know they're
spaying and neutering all our animals
that that's not happening we
don't we're we're not allowed by law we
can only do Emergency
Care the expectation that police
departments and Animal Control Officers
have expertise required to determine
cruelty and neglect is often not
realistic there's no certification for
Animal Control Officers police officers
do not have a specialty in Animal
Welfare or
husbandry they contact us routinely to
provide that expertise this is what we
do every day 365 days a year this week
we've assisted Alexandria PD Rawlings
Spirit at Hampton and the list
continues if Lucky they rarely have to
deal with animal cases and quite frankly
they don't want
to it's fear of what will they do with
the animals honestly what will they do
with the animals when they seize them
where are they going to go and they take
them into protective custody where are
they going to go if you're not allowing
our Humane agents to be on the property
who's going to take them and when you
say local farms the State Vet calls us
that's who they call they do call some
local farms but they often call us they
call us and they call another sanctuary
in the state of New
Hampshire the police do not know about
the cost of care fund that now exists or
how to apply for it our agents recently
presented at a sheriff's meeting
furthering our efforts to educate them
on the process and the procedure we've
actually put it in our empowerment
contracts about cost of care we've put
it in our cruelty legislation we put it
in our M we are trying to educate police
we are trying to educate prosecutors
about the 14-day status hearing so that
these cases don't go on and get
continued and continued and
continued to eliminate Humane agents
ability to take animals into protective
custody the recommendation of licensed
veterinarians and require cruelty
charges on any case will only increase
suffering and inflict greater pain and
the cost to those who are at greatest
risk individuals with mental illness who
are have Financial inability or physical
ability to
care for these reasons the New Hampshire
SPCA urges you to oppose House Bill
616 thank you for your time and I'm
happy to answer any questions are there
any questions representative
Freeman thank you Mr chairman thank you
for coming in front of us
um I have the same almost exactly the
same question for you as I had for M Lee
sure would you not agree that this RS an
RSA such as this would protect your
organization as well as the public
interest I don't think it would protect
the public interest and I don't think it
would protect animals because what
you're doing is you're implying that
police officers are the ones required
first of all in order to get a search
warrant you have to involve the police
the police are the ones who get
complaints who call us that happened in
Lee you know it doesn't just happen from
citizens it happens also from the police
departments um they call us all the time
that they're getting complaints and
they're not they don't know what to do
they want us to come out they want us to
advise they want us to assist so in this
case I think that there are it's not
going to improve I think mandating that
you have cruelty charges instead of the
death by um unauthorized
taking I think that there are so many
times when there's mental illness we
took 39 cats from a gentleman and you
know the police knew him very well
Social Services were working with them
he had 39 cats in his bed including
tapeworm and all kinds of other
parasites our goal was not to charge him
you know that's not going to be helpful
and also people can go out and get more
animals so our goal is to educate and to
assist and support and provide lowcost
spay neuters to help people with those
overpopulation issues things like that
you're
welcome representative H Haskins thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question two questions sure um do you
believe that the
SPCA acted honorably in the Lee case and
if so is there anything that you would
have done differently so first of all um
to clarify an earlier Point as well
there was I thought there were nine
staff members there might have been
seven some somewhere between seven and
nine were on site that day in terms of
who was there plus the two veterinarians
that may have even included them but
I'll let the the other
uh individuals reference that um is
there anything we would have done
differently we'd gone I I believe and I
think that if you when you hear from uh
ton and Michelle they can speak more
specifically because they were on site
in advance I was only on site for
mediation which we're not supposed to
talk about so I'm not going to talk
about mediation which I didn't even know
existed through the USDA but it was a
you know it was we were there in good
faith um and trying to come to some sort
of agreement
so would anything have been done
differently I I can't say that I have
the initial
information to speak to that I really
would want the others speak to it but I
I honestly believe no I don't because I
did see the animals I saw the animals
when they came arrived at the
SPCA I saw them in the coming weeks I
know what the conditions were in there I
saw enough of the photographs it was
heart-wrenching to me it was really
heart-wrenching and it was
get me wrong we don't want to take them
in right we have to then care for them
and when we have large numbers of
animals we have to care for them well
beyond our 8 to four hours and it costs
a lot of money and you're not going to
get it back so no it's not you know we
don't go out seizing animals for the fun
of it so to speak there has to be you
know probable cause there could have
been charges there was a surrender in
that case um so that those charges did
not come
forth thank you he representative King
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony and taking
questions um when a bill is drafted uh
lots of times it hits a lot of different
sections and subsections of rsas in the
attempt to provide more protections
you've clearly spoken out against the
bill and I think you've made some solid
points on some certain issues but I'm
just wondering if there's any part of
the bill that you like one part I'm
thinking of that I don't think you
address maybe you did I apologize if you
did but um on the first page subsection
two um the person charged this would be
added to the current language the person
charged shall be made aware of this and
then of course there be need to be
another amendment to put the word
ability in ability to petition and
writing the arresting officer do you do
you think even that is totally uncalled
for or no I you know we would have
welcomed a vet if if they if we had
gotten a call saying you know we'd like
our vet to come out and
look at the animals so be it you know
they're professional licensed
individuals that we respect we hire vets
we have vets on staff so um that's not
an issue I think that what you have to
do however is somehow you have to build
it into the documentation because if you
expect the police to give that
documentation that's where it's going to
fall apart um but if it's on a search
warrant if it's on a seizure if it's on
you know something that the individual
has to sign
that it clearly states that they can
have a vet of their choosing come out
and do an invest you know uh examine the
animals that would that you know that's
fine okay so it's not the whole bill
it's just some parts of the bill you're
totally against other parts you're okay
with sure okay thank
you uh yes representative rubert uh
thank you uh and thank you for taking a
question um would you be willing to
provide back to us in writing which
areas the bill you think you would
support um and areas that rather than I
I would love to say that I could do it
by tomorrow but I can't I think to
tomorrow but would that be helpful
because I I would certainly be willing
to look at it and see if there were you
know if there were elements that we felt
would strengthen the law you know I it's
it's so simple in some
ways the police don't know to call the
Department of a for
support I'll tell you that they they
don't I called them I called the
department of a twice a couple of weeks
ago begging them to assist us in a case
and they said no that's law enforcement
that's an animal welfare issue that's
law
enforcement so the law enforcement
called but they called Public Health
they didn't call the Department of a so
the department of a didn't come out so
there's just so much misinformation out
there it's challenging and even though
the department of a distributes
information you know there's Transitions
and all kinds of things it's very hard
so you know we sit there people know to
call us and we work in partnership with
with the police we call them to let them
know we're going into that town right
we're sending individuals by themselves
it's a safety issue we want them to know
that we're on site but yes I'd be happy
to work with our team and and look at
this I'm not an expert in law but I'm
happy to do it just a quick follow as as
mentioned earlier here these bills they
go through amendments modifications we
we try to listen carefully to all the
parties understand things and trying to
trying to change things in a way that
are systemic right and um and not kind
of generic we just don't like the like
right so that this would be helpful
thank you yeah and it's important I mean
I know this is
a I I think it's important to look at
all the cases as I said you
know there's almost 600 cases a year of
which almost 300 are large animals you
don't want to change law based on one
case necessarily you know if there's
Improvement so be it but you have you
know this generally is working repres SC
you're welcome thank you Mr chair and
again thank you for coming before us so
I was just wondering I mean people call
in and I would think that'd be like
three categories one who's somebody's
doing something maliciously somebody
who's doing something with good
intentions but it's just wrong and then
there's a legitimate uh situation that
they're identifying for you sure how do
you uh screen those things you know to
make sure that we're not sure bothering
people that shouldn't be bothered right
and I and I really would love to defer
those to the two agents that we have
here we have two I have you know both of
our Humane agents are here today and
they can speak specifically as they
receive the calls every single day but I
can tell you generically that depending
upon where it is we get calls all over
the state from Berlin to Keen etc etc is
that you may be calling a local police
and asking them to go do a check first
because you don't want to be driving
three and four hours to find out that it
was a neighborly dispute because that
happens right you get divorce cases you
get all kinds of cases but sometimes
animals are in imminent danger and so
you want to know but again the police
officers are not necessarily experts
especially in livestock and equin you
know many more police officers have cats
and dogs than they do large animals but
you also May reach out to your local
animal control officer sometimes it
warrants a trip out there to do an
investigation to to see what you can see
to talk to the owner of the animals to
find out is there any validity to the
case to see the animals things like
that follow up all right thank you so
you for every call that comes in you are
assuming on face value that it is
legitimate and you're sending at least
somebody out to look at the situation we
assume that it's an individual with a
concern whether it's legitimate or not
is yet to be
determined more quickly well how do you
determine that you have you have a
police officer go out and check you have
you have somebody you know you call the
individual and find out you know you you
reach out in some capacity to learn more
you have to start by learning more thank
you you're welcome
okay um I have um just a question in
terms of General procedures um so uh we
heard testimony that uh that the uh
seizures took place on a 93 degree day
is there do you have in your policies
anything that takes into account the
possible effects of weather conditions
on the animals that You' be dealing with
um we certainly take certain things into
consideration you know when is the
search warrant executed what is the time
frame what's the imminent D you know
there are a number of elements we try
and time things so that it's better than
worse but if you're in a heat wave your
days to execute a search warrant may not
change okay thank you you're welcome are
there any other
questions okay thank you so
much next Rob Johnson from the Farm
Bureau thank you Mr chair m the
committee for the record Rob Johnson and
The New Hampshire Farm Bureau
representing our uh nearly 2500 members
and we are in support of the bill I've
been before you before mentioned we had
kind of three bills in this area coming
and this is the the third of those three
and it's been stated previously we've
been working with the sponsors of the
bill and and the department uh on it and
we believe that it it uh provides some
due process for animal owners in the law
some clarity some consistency and also
some flexibility uh for the the
particularly for the uh State Vet and
the Department of Agriculture there
are 10 or so areas uh where substantive
changes are made in the animal cruelty
statutes and then I'd like to speak to
basically three I'm going to
highlight I'll St I'll start with on
page page one uh where the the language
is struck in line 19 and 20 uh officer
of a duly licensed Humane
Society um we strongly believe that uh
any such action should be taken by a
public
official uh whether it be as is already
in the statute a law enforcement officer
or an animal control officer and we
would ask that the the bill be amended
to clarify that further by saying
Municipal Animal control
officer um it's a police action that's
taking place this is the criminal
code there's just no
oversight when we're talking an officer
of a duly licensed Humane Society what
what exactly does that mean I know it
was testified previously that they it's
a a former retired police officer the
way it's worded it could be the
president vice president treasur
Secretary of a of a licensed uh uh
Humane Society it it's uh it's
confusing to to animal owners when when
uh you know there somebody in this
capacity shows up an officer of a
licensed Humane Society is they I've
I've gotten on I've been with F beer now
for nearly 25 years and there's been a
couple occasions where I've got phone
calls from Members asking what what's
this all who are these people and and
you know again it's it's confusing so
that I'm going to just um the the
uh second area I'd like to to highlight
is where you see and I'll it's in a few
places but line five where lines four
and five where it says a state
veterinarian or their design and it's
their design I want to highlight and
then you look on page two line 10
veterinarian or their
design page
uh three line 22 20 21 21 and 22 State
veteran or their design and what what
that does is again we believe this
provides some
flexibility uh for the State Vet where
that design again it could be a a
licensed veterinarian it could be one of
the uh technicians in the the Office of
the State
veterinarian or it could be another
individual that the state veterinarian
believes has the capacity and and
understanding and knowledge to to you
know go out and take a look uh for them
to see if it is a a situation that
justifies the expertise of a vet going
out uh already happens now that on
occasion uh we have members where their
local law enforcement agency will call
them and say we they've got a complaint
and ask the farmer to go out and take a
look just again all of these situations
are pro where the design is not is
providing
uh advice to law enforcement or the
state vet to experts they're not they're
not dealing with the the owner it's
again that's that it's it's where the
the uh individual is again uh providing
advice to to uh officials and then to to
what goes along with that is you'll see
that I wanted to point out uh in
line uh page three line six where where
it it uh provides uh um liability
protection not just to a veterinarian
but also to an individual who who who is
uh assisting you know officials in an
investigation so that way the again the
that was one issue when we we talked
about this with our members they were
concerned about you know liability um uh
and this this would again like like we
currently have for a veterinarian uh
provide some liability protection and
then the third area I wanted to touch on
uh in the law is just I mentioned it it
it brings some uh Clarity consistency
and if you again this has been touched
on before but you on page one uh lines
uh 9 and 10 under uh confiscation it
provides for that the for a a uh
examination by a vet at the animal
owner's expense and that they need to be
made aware of this that's in the case of
a confiscation and then you look on uh
page two
lines uh 678
uh where again it now provides the same
thing for where an animal is taken in
protective custody and that's not
currently the case in both situations
where those are provided so it is in
consistent um I will I will close at
that I'll be I'll be part of the the
work session tomorrow but other than
that I couple other things I wanted to
highlight is one don't forget the the
cost of care language that we had HED to
incorporate into this when we get into
the work session and and just in in some
of the some of the specific of the
situation in Lee um I wanted to point
out
that the comments been made that you
know you shouldn't make law based on one
case this is not one case not at all
over time there have been others there
is a uh a similar situation at the same
time that uh I received a phone call on
uh from a uh somebody with horses uh
based on the record recation of that
veterinarian and this incident happened
um this past spring it was in May and I
received the phone call in October this
person had not talked to anybody about
this in similar to what what what Donna
Lee I believe had mentioned to you this
person said the way she was treated it
was I felt post-traumatic stress she was
embarrassed she was
horrified
um you know as as my wife works in the
healthcare field and and uh she's
probably visiting nurses and goes into
homes and she'll tell you it's not
uncommon to find people who have uh
animals from dogs and cats to chickens
in their home and those people probably
can't rub to Nickel together but by
goodness they're going to make sure that
those animals eat and are comfortable
beyond anything else and that includes
their own care and sometimes her job is
to tr against them that you've got to
take care of yourself first so
um it's it's it's
uh this this individual was in that type
of situation where I think in some of
these cases somebody's uh you might look
at that property from the outside and it
may not be what we all think a home
should look like that does not mean that
the animals and being well cared for and
I I I guess just again based on the the
years I've been doing this J that seems
to be the case sometimes where uh some
people are jumping to conclusions a
little early on on some things uh in in
regard to again to to darn Lee I just
want to point out but she didn't say it
that uh she was has been and has
currently been work working with uh
Dairy specialist from the University and
I know that because shortly after this
the incident happened with her I was
called by one of them just absolutely
disgusted to think that they knew her
operation they knew her animals and they
never received a phone call or anything
and that this was happening to her they
were quite upset
um and as you can all imagine it's her
name too I I mean she participated in a
couple farmers markets in the state and
one of them gave her the boot with with
with just just on the the you know the
press the media stuff
um and I'll close with just saying that
it was it was mentioned that that uh
there were officials from the State
Department of Agriculture from the state
vet staff on site and in in in Donal
Le's instance and um I would just ask
you to SP uh speak with the Department
of Agriculture as to why they did what
they did before before uh just jump to
any conclusions and like again I thank
you for your time and uh I'll leave it
at that would you be willing to take
questions certainly representative King
thank you Mr chair uh thank you for your
testimony and taking questions I'm
curious if there are any parts of the
bill that you don't like I'm
specifically thinking of uh page one
lines 15 and
16 um about the idea that um you know
you can't individuals or organizations
wouldn't be able to solicit donations I
can understand that under the current
statute there's a perverse incentive
where an a nonprofit might that's also
in the in the uh business of
confiscation might therefore be you know
making money off of that but if you get
rid of that um like in the next
subsection you get rid of let's say a a
nonprofit having anything to do with it
now it really is fully in control of the
state then there isn't that perverse
incentive anymore how would you feel
about getting rid of lines 15 and 16
what I think we would certainly be open
to to amendment I I know you I heard
what you mentioned earlier and and yeah
that that wasn't thought of when we put
it together I mean obviously we worked
on this with the sponsors and the
department so we're we you know we're we
were very comfortable with it but we
realize it's not perfect I know the
commissioner also had some suggestions
that that obviously deserve a close look
thank you yes representative Freeman
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in front of us this afternoon I
just something that came up with a bill
that's similar to this about having two
law enforcement offices trained um one
of the things that was pointed out and
actually in testimony was pointed out
that we have an RSA on the book and
books and I don't know if you know this
but we have an RSA on the books that
states when an Leo responds to a
complaint of animal cruelty a vet is
supposed to be called so I I'm not sure
anybody has full knowledge of that RSA
so I'm wondering if you know about that
R we certainly do for for livestock a a
a a veterinarian needs to make the
probable cause of termination yes that's
something that we're very aware of and
and you're you're correct yes at the
hearing one I guess one of a lot
enforcement officials asked and said
that they did not know and I think that
is the case yeah follow up yes thank you
so so really the Leo is not responsible
for determining if there is a case of
animal cruelty or or neglect with
livestock correct and that's part of
what we're trying to accomplish in the
bill to make clear it is not law
enforcement we do not want them making
those decisions and in most cases they
understand they don't have the expertise
and the knowledge but they need to know
where to get that okay and one more
followup thank you so much that's part
of that bill if you're not not going to
study thank you so much for indulging Me
So based on what the vet will tell the
Leo the Leo will proceed with whatever
criminal charges
would be put on that particular owner is
that correct yeah they'll make the
determination best on the expertise
provided correct thank you very much Mr
chair if I can just add one thing that I
had I wanted to mention uh Donal
mentioned that her you know she has
school groups and tours of the farm she
does that at no charge that that is
something a public service that that she
and I just wanted to bring that up
because she did mention it thank you
thank you any other questions from Mr
Johnson no
well all right you're free next uh
Michelle merch from the New Hampshire
sbca hello I am Michelle merch I'm also
sorry I'm Michelle merch I also live in
Lee um I am currently a the ecoin and
farm program manager for the New
Hampshire SPCA as well as a cruelty
investigator I am a retired law
enforcement officer from um the cities
of do and Durham after 24 years um I am
writing to oppose House Bill 616 for
several significant concerns about its
impact on the effective effectiveness of
animal cruelty investigations and the
welfare of animals in the state of New
Hampshire as a former law enforcement
officer ecoin and farm program manager
and Humane agent I believe I bring
valuable insight into the Practical
realities of investigating animal
cruelty and the essential role that
Humane agents play in safeguarding the
animals of our
state house bill 616 proposes that the
state veterinarian or their design be
the vet of record on cruelty
investigations while I respect the
expertise of our state veterinarians the
volume of Cruelty cases that are occur
on an annual basis far exceeds the
capacity for their small team of
veterinarians to effectively manage
cruelty investigations often require
timely timely on-site assessments and
Swift swift interventions particularly
when animals are in immediate danger the
state veterinarian with all due respect
would be overwhelmed by the sheer number
of cases potentially leading to delays
in intervention and compromising the
welfare of animals involved according to
New Hampshire law currently livestock
cannot be seized without the direction
of a licensed
veterinarian this law ensures that
seizures are done responsibly and with
proper expertise large animal
veterinarians or veterinarians with
expertise in livestock are the only
veterinarians used during large animal
cruelty investigations I have spoken to
veterinarians on site at
investigations when I don't have a vet
that I'm local to I call a
veterinarian's office and if they are
not familiar with livestock they will
not assist me they absolutely will not
so I cannot get a cat doctor to come out
and seize a horse just to be
clear Humane agents are special are
specialists in animal welfare and have
the necessary experience to handle the
intricacies of animal cruelty
investigations they are trained not only
in the laws that protect animals but
also the best practices for ensuring the
well-being of animals in distress By REM
removing Humane Agents from the
investigative process House Bill 616
would leave animals at a much greater
risk of harm many police officers while
well-meaning do not possess the same
level of expertise when it comes to
handling animal cruelty cases Humane
agents play a crucial role working with
law enforcement and veterinarians
ensuring that the animals are not only
protected but also the investigations
are carried out in accordance with the
law and compassion for the animals
involved law law enforcement looks to
Humane agents for support in conducting
investigations and sharing their
expertise
police officers are simply not equipped
to handle the complexities of animal
cruelty cases in the same way Humane
agents are without proper training and
expertise officers may fail to
understand the nuances of Animal Welfare
laws leading to potential mishandling of
cases or missed opportunities to protect
animals as a former law enforcement
officer I spent 24 years on the job I
was um on the mounted Patrol so I cared
for Animals whenever cruelty
investigations came up it was shocking
to all of us we didn't handle enough of
them we had to look for animal control
officer if she was not available we
would look to Humane agents because we
would have to go back to the law and try
to figure out the Dynamics of it because
we handled one every sever every several
years it wasn't something we did on a
regular basis so you need someone that
has some expertise and veterinarians are
not always available either you know so
you have to have other people in the
field besides just police officers
they're
very very busy doing a lot of other
things Humane agents focus on animals
it's just you know what we do so that's
where our expertise
lies um challenges in requiring officers
to inform defendants of animal
examinations the bill also requires the
law enforcement officers to inform those
charged with animal cruelty that they
can petition the court to have a
veterinarian of their choosing exam
examine the animals in writing this
provision is highly unrealistic as Law
Enforcement Officers receive very little
specialized training in animal cruelty
Beyond a minimum of 2-hour block at the
police academy the current law includes
this information without requiring
officers to ensure defendants are aware
in writing animals are evidence in
cruelty investigations in many cruelty
investigations the animals are the
evidence of the case and are seized or
taken into protective custody during the
investigation as with any criminal
investigation charg charges are not
immediately filed unless they are Fel
level charges there are exent
circumstances or the crime was committed
in an officer's presence and not all
crimes involving animals are intentional
it's important to recognize that not all
acts of Cruelty we frequently frequently
deal with elderly individuals people
with mental illness or others who may
unintentionally neglect or harm their
animals due to lack of understanding
cognitive decline or other
circumstances in these cases law
enforcement and Humane agents must have
the discretion to determine the
appropriate course of action whether it
involves education intervention or
assistance removing discretion would
lead to unjust consequences particularly
for vulnerable individuals who may need
support rather than punitive action in
conclusion I urge you to reconsider the
provisions of House Bill 616 they would
undermine the effec effectiveness of
animal cruelty investigations and place
animals in the state of New Hampshire at
greater risk Humane agents are essential
in protecting the welfare of animals and
removing them from the process would be
detrimental to our ability to respond to
cruelty in a timely and effective manner
additionally removing discretion from
law enforcement would lead to
unnecessary and harmful consequences for
those who unintentionally harm their
animals I ask to vote against 616 and
maintain the important role of Humane
agents in investigative investigation
and protection of
animals thank you would you be willing
to take questions yes okay uh
representative wheeler
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question Miss merch um my question
given the fact that uh there are not
officers who know how to handle these
animal cruelty situations according to
your testimony can you tell us why you
went from being an officer to the
SPCA I retired from law enforcement so I
was finished being a police officer I
had enough after 24 years um and I am
very passionate about animals and animal
welfare and I started um initially I
wanted to be a cruelty investigator to
help protect the animals um I started to
look into the laws the you know lack of
consistency in laws I was interested in
it um I became the equinum farm program
manager which means I am in charge of
taking care of all the large animals
outside that is my job to rehab
rehabilitate and rehome that is my
primary responsibility the shelter and
the more that I became involved in
rehabbing and re in rehoming those
animals and rescuing them the more
passionate I came became about making
sure they were protected um we see some
awful things I was in law enforcement
for 24 years I saw some awful things
there animal cruelty is far worse um the
things that we see at people's homes are
is devastating um some of the hardest
things I've ever seen in my life have
been in the F past four years involving
animals and many many times it's not
intentional people become overwhelmed
they're embarrassed they don't know
where to ask for help even though we're
here and we do not judge they don't
necessarily always come to us family and
friends don't always step up until after
the police or Humane agents or whoever
steps in um so it it's it's something
I'm very passionate about and um um
that's why I got
involved thank you for taking that
question and I having been on the
criminal justice committee remember the
animal cruelty cases that we would hear
about and it is something it's some of
the worst things that happen in the
state it really is now my second
question to do with what you just said
equin and this is kind of a maybe a
silly question but I want to get an
answer to it anyway equin I was under
the impression that it meant horse it
does okay you said it handles all large
animals so I so I'm the equin and farm
program manager I see and f farm I may
have left that out no no worries thank
you hey represent
ger thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so you had said that
you know if you contacted a vet and they
were a cat doctor for example that they
wouldn't take a call to go out and look
at at livestock for example u i I was
doing a little bit of poking around
online looking at the warrant
information that was shared with us and
it does seem that the veterinarian who
was brought in in this case to look at
Goats was a specialist in small animal
internal medicine and whose experience
was primarily in a um in a Veterinary
situation that dealt with with uh
domesticated pets are you referring to
Dr Boer yes uh so yes so if I I'm sorry
I didn't mean to cut you off I just
didn't get to my question uh which is so
do you think that that a doctor with
that kind of training I don't know much
about the transferability of Medical
Training but somebody with that kind of
experience and training is suitable to
be making these kinds of serious
judgments with regards to farm animals
so all veterinarians go to school to
study all animals they learn about all
animals when they're in um when they are
um at school then they specialize um Dr
lawyer was the the vet of record at a
state fair for large animals previously
and she is a USDA vet as well so she
does have experience that currently she
is practicing cats and dogs just like I
used to be a police officer we all have
past and some of us have more experience
than others all right that helps thank
you very much
yeah my representative
sky thank you Mr chair um thank you
again for being here and educating us
sure I appreciate it um now you you were
concerned about the removal of Humane
agents I don't remember seeing that in
the language of the bill itself is it
referring to the fact that we you're
we're asking for a Veterinary instead of
somebody else who somebody designated as
a Humane agent no in the bill it's
Humane agent is struck out oh part of
the language that was struck I didn't
pay a lot of attention to that yeah
that's a page one line
2021 thank thank you um can you please
tell me what a Humane agent is what the
definition of a Humane agent is so we
are um authorized by our um agency a
Humane agency um to we receive
complaints um and we are tasked with um
deciding whether like you asked before
whether the complaints are um Justified
or not so a lot of times we act as
um the middleman and we we um give these
complaints to Animal Control Officers
that you know are in different towns um
or we try to determine the validity of
the complaints ourselves so we are uh
individuals that
are set out
to um investigate cruelty um or neglect
so we are the um unsworn investigator
years for cruelty investigations you
have a followup please okay um so are
you working for the SPCA yes okay now
are there um training and certification
requirements not in the state of New
Hampshire okay thank
you okay uh representative King thank
you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony and answering questions today
um since the Lee case happened
um um the the farmers in that case
they've they've experienced um some
tremendous backlash within their own
Community um
prejudices um it's been probably pretty
bad for the reputation I'm but but it
sounds like there's a lot of um
controversy over this issue have you
noticed any backlash to the
SPCA um as a result of the handling of
this case have you noticed um any any
negative or negative feelings amongst
the community since especially since you
live in Lee at the same the same
location have you noticed any backlash
against the SPCA um I think Lisa would
be better to speak to that um I think as
far as an investigator I do not feel
that we've had any issues um going out
to other Farms if that's what you're um
you know asking um we've had some people
that I've spoken to um in Lee that
weren't happy with what happened but
also many of them um only had heard one
side of the story um obviously under you
know an any situation there's more than
one side to every story um so with a a
bigger under a larger understanding of
the entire picture I think that it uh we
were able to share um our side and I do
understand that without charging Donna
Le it led to
more um
just Stories being told on you know
whoever side you were on so there was no
um Court decision made on on what
happened um but personally I've had no
issues I've being the farm program
manager I haven't received any personal
um you know situations that were of
concern okay thank
you representative
wheeler thank you Mr chair
you had said in your response to
representative Scully that there were no
training requirements for the SPCA in
the state of New Hampshire I'm wondering
if you could answer although this is
probably more appropriate for Lisa the
people who are hired by the SPCA are
they generally former police officers
and things along those line that is one
of um the things that Lisa um looks for
when she's hiring hemain agents because
we do have
um we do have a background in
investigations um and in law enforcement
and law so we also try to on our own um
continue to educate ourselves um we do
take classes online um but there is no
State requirement the SPCA isn't just
plucking people off the street though
no so um I have a question about uh one
of the um there there are there are two
areas in uh section 6448 that allow the
seizure of animals uh one is when
someone is being charged with a uh with
animal cruelty the other is protective
custody and uh can you
explain how those two work and what the
respon the due process
responsibilities uh are under those so
um
obviously um
when an animal is taken into protective
custody if we're speaking about
livestock um it doesn't matter if
they're um under any circumstances with
livestock they it has to be a
veterinarian's decision um so it's not a
law enforce even if the animal is dying
in front of me and I am there if it is a
horse I cannot seize that animal even to
save its life unless I have a
veterinarian's approval that has
actually happened to me on more than one
occasion and that is a very difficult
situation to handle um so um and uh so
animals are taken only without a warrant
small animals are only taken without a
warrant if they are in imminent danger
um that is the only time that they are
taken without a warrant um we do not nor
do law enforcement go and just pluck
animals from people's backyards that
does not happen um so animals are seized
as evidence from a search warrant and
they are taken into protective custody
while the case proceeds um and they are
the living evidence for that case um
animals taken into protective custody um
whether it's because they are not well
and they need to be cared for properly
um they will be taken and depending on
what happens whether the Court decides
the officers decide to go forward with
charges or not the animals are returned
afterwards if they if um the if they're
not surrendered many times they are
surrendered okay and if the
uh if the animals are taken as evidence
are the responsibilities in terms of
what sort of changes may or may not be
made to the animals legally if they are
part of evidence being held we would
take the animals and we would hold them
as evidence the only thing we are
allowed to do is keep them alive
basically we provide necessary medical
care and we feed and house them um we
aren't allowed to alter them we aren't
allowed to train them we aren't allowed
to do anything with them until the case
is disposed of okay so if they are
euthanized does that consider is that
considered being a change the only way
we can euthanize an animal that is in
protective custody or that is evidence
we must petition the court or get
permission from the owner of the animals
even if they're being charged with a
crime we do not euthanize
animals without their knowledge okay
thank you representative Penza uh thank
you Mr chair um that
just brings up a question then so in in
this case and I don't we don't want to
get here to debate this case um you know
22 animals when they were seized were um
were killed so how do we explain that
that happening they were
surrendered the animals were surrendered
after they were taken into protective
custody they were surrendered by
Donal I don't that that doesn't I don't
know I'm sorry follow up I don't
understand what you mean so the animals
were seized the the two veterinarians on
scene
told law enforcement that the animals
needed to be taken into protective
custody MH the animals were taken into
protective custody and then the animals
were then surrendered to the New
Hampshire
SPCA okay but that's not I'm talking
about the 22 of them that were then
killed and they were euthanized at the
recommendation of a veterinarian after
they were surrendered because they were
suffering
are there any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank
you okay oh next uh I'd like to call
Stacy Ober and um if people could keep
their testimony on the short side uh
that would be very good uh obviously
we're running a bit long
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Stacy Ober I'm the
New England government relations manager
for the American Kennel Club I have some
written testimony that's General I do
think it's um such a useful opportunity
to sit through the testimony so I want
to tailor my oral testimony to you uh
specific to some of what you heard
today a few years ago the American
Kennel Club worked closely with New
Hampshire dogs and this committee on
strengthening the animal cruelty statute
and the work was done in a reflection of
two uh dog cruelty cases one which ended
in a conviction and another where the CH
the charges had been dropped and so I
want to just reiterate that you know the
American Kennel Club does take a strong
line on animal cruelty we have policies
that suspend privileges and we actually
have an invest tigation inspection
program most people don't know about and
regardless of the number of dogs someone
owns if they're treating a dog
negligently or cruy they should be held
responsible there are Provisions in
house 616 that we support because I
believe it's strengthens the language
that was adopted in the work with this
committee a couple of years ago so I
wanted to just highlight what those
were um and I think the bill will
clarify the proper procedure and some
awareness around the statute's
provisions um you heard that there's a
focus on educating and not bringing
charges the animal cruelty case the dog
cruelty case that resulted in a
conviction was a mental health issue the
individual in fact um was ordered by the
court to undergo some psychological
treatment so in the event the animal
neglect and cruelty is the result of a
mental health condition in fact it may
be wise to go forward with charges so
that treatment could ensue in that
situation rather than allowing for
instance someone who's hoarding animals
to go out and um continue to collect
them the um Provisions that were
included and I want to turn to in the
bill if you look
at line
seven a person charged under this
section May petition the court to seek
an examination of the Animals by a
veterinarian licensed of his or her
choice at the expense of the person in
charged that language was put in statute
as a reflection of a dog owner whose
whose dogs had been seized uh one of the
dogs they did charge for neglect and in
fact the dog was an elderly dog that had
a medical issue and was under the care
and treatment of a veterinarian so I
think these cases can be quite complex
and um they can be quite emotional in
that instance my understanding is the
charges were eventually dropped um and
the individual had to enter into kind of
a confidentiality agreement to not talk
about it because it was quite
embarrassing uh that the Humane Society
had gone forward with these charges and
drawn it out the legal expense the
negative media coverage it was it was
quite
ugly so sometimes people are innocent
and um that's why we put this language
in there and I think it would be a great
help to add the sentence that making the
person aware
um that they have the opportunity to
hire a veterinarian the other piece that
we put into law was to expedite these
cases so that that was in the best
interest for everyone the animals the
defendant and prosecution and to have
the court conduct a status hearing
within 14 days of the seizure what I
don't know because I'm not a prosecutor
or in law enforcement
is whether or not the status Hearing in
front of the court requires charges to
be filed at that time my experience in
covering New England is that sometimes
animals are seized and it can be weeks
or months before charges are actually
filed um so I just wanted to flag that
for you all and whether or not there
would be uh a desire
to you know I don't know whether that's
appropriate or logical to be able to
ensure that a period is um given for
charges to either be filed or or not
filed
um the last piece I wanted to highlight
is the language that you've been talking
about on the page
one the new subparagraph starting in
line
13 no confiscated animals shall be
altered without the notorized
authorization of the owner from whom the
animal was
confiscated um sorry the next sentence
nor shall such animal or animals be used
in any manner to solicit donations or to
fundraise by any individual or
organization um that language I think
would be incredibly um important and and
useful even if you clarified that that
sentence is with respect to any uh
individual or organization that has
custody of the
animal rather than the defendant who
might be doing a a you know some kind of
a fundraising which does happen when
somebody's faced with a situation of
having to hire legal counsel um the
reason I think it's
important is that you've heard even from
your own committee members some of the
harassment that has taken place um in
the media sometimes these pictures are
used on social media to um create an
emotional appeal for donations and I
want to just pause and make an analogy
for
you in the event law enforcement let's
say needed to hire an expert assistant
for an investigation let's say it was a
white collar crime and they needed to
hire an accountant to look whether the
books were being cooked or something
like
that typically what happens is law
enforcement will enter a non-disclosure
agreement that professional is not
allowed to assist with the investigation
and then go out and call People magazine
or somebody else you know and get paid
for sharing the information that they
only have been exposed to or acquired by
virtue of their as an expert assistant
and so um I think there were a number of
negative consequences of it um to allow
that to happen and that would include
not only um harassment or intentional
infliction of emotional distress maybe
um also compromising the investigation
itself and certainly it lends to a
perception of impropriety if you're
going to allow the organization that
filed the complaint to then go in and do
the investigation and then use that
evidence to raise funds and make
donations it creates a real appearance
of impropriety so thanks for letting me
just cover those points with you
today thank you and uh would you be
willing to take questions absolutely are
there any
questions seeing none looks like you're
off the hook all right thank you next
I'd like to call Kurt aronberg from the
human society
good afternoon representative Bixby and
the committee uh I'll be brief I
uh I just think it's important
uh that it's said here today that the
SPCA the Animal Rescue League and all of
the other animal welfare organizations
that take care of animals that are
involved in animal adoption that do
animal rescues on a daily basis basis
Tona and Michelle are
essential parts of the law enforcement
of this state that takes care of animals
and without them there would be more
animals suffering in this
state um to have this bill attack these
organizations to deny them uh nonprofit
organizations from fundraising
and to say that they cannot be involved
in animal rescue large animal rescues in
this state should not be what we do here
in this
committee um so I thought that needed to
be said here today I was not going to
testify I think the experts are clearly
here to
testify um on both
sides um but I do think that this bill
in its form right
now takes away some of the tools and and
we're trying and this committee is a big
part of that also the governor's
Commission on the Humane treatment of
animals is very concerned which I'm a
member of very concerned with the state
of animal protection and the law
enforcement Community where this
committee is working on that in other
areas
uh I would say this bill in many ways is
at odds with that effort and and and
that's all I want to say today thank you
thank you um would you be willing to
take questions no I don't think I need
to take questions thanks thank
you next I like to call uh Chuck Cox
from
Lee yeah Chuck Cox uh tuck away Farm Lee
New Hampshire um I'm certainly in
support of the bill I think there have
been some uh I've been personally
involved well you know with the things
that have been going on in Lee um I
think the first thing when I heard this
news that there was some herd of goats
that was being seized for Mal treatment
it never crossed my mind that it would
have been Donna Le's Farm cuz I know
what was happening so that was you know
just you know who who could have goats
that would been mistreated in
Lee um I guess the main thing
um thing I'm very concerned with is
the perception that we have of people in
general and it may be an educational
thing or or whatnot of what
is um you got complaints from people
they see an animal they think oh that's
being mistr and as a farm you know we're
try to be as open as we can to you know
public and have people in but we were
certainly getting gun shy we have some U
Kaden sheep which shed their wool
they're not they're not shorn but they
shed the wool and they look horrible at
that point and if you get someone coming
in and saying oh gee
they're you know they're and there sheep
are falling apart and stuff and we get
people come in and this the same thing
uh we've had a number of horses and we
keep them some they get old and
sometimes you just can't keep weight on
them and do you have to put them back
where no one can see them that you know
these being they're getting full care
that they can get full food and and
everything else but you get this feeling
that someone's going to come up and you
know say you're m treating these these
animals um I can go on uh you we also
keep the hounds for the Wentworth hunt
um and uh you know we have you know very
good care on all of that but I think the
other thing I think that's underneath a
lot of this is it's um I think we get
sort of the animal
rights um thing coming in too that oh
gee you know I've been involved with
sled dogs too and they said oh gee those
sled dogs are Chang up they're being
mistreated nothing those sled dogs like
better than in to run and get hitched up
and go the same with the hounds and
you're saying well gee they're kept in
the pen they're not getting they're
getting well cared for they're getting
their food and the people that are
keeping these animals are very concerned
that that's their Prime thing and I
think we just got to watch that
um uh we've got to uh educate the public
I don't know that uh you know they don't
know
you know what is proper care they get
this other idea of you know
um uh that they need all this or that
and the you know the Care on horses and
what that uh you know they provide
shelter but often you worst thing
they're standing out in the in the wind
and stuff and they're happier there than
they are being confined other places so
I think there's a lot of this thing that
has to be very uh watched very closely
that uh some people's
um um feeling of what is proper care and
what is is not I think it's very
different in the farm
situation um and
uh well I guess I'll just uh leave it at
that uh would you be willing to take
questions I would are there any are
there any
questions I guess you're off the hook
thank you for coming
in next uh uh Tana
McCarthy and if I pronounced that wrong
then um please correct me
my name is Tona McCarthy and I am the
Humane agent and quty investigator from
New Hampshire SPCA in
Strat dear members of the House
environment and agriculture committee on
behalf of the New Hampshire Society
prevention to cruelity animals I want to
submit to testimony oppos the bill of
616 I am running to express my strong
opposition of Bill 16 which is currently
under
consideration I'm retired in law
enforcement and have been and will
continue to protect any animal that has
been neglected as a Humane officer the
resident of New Hampshire I am deeply
concerned about negative impact this
legislation could have with Bill
616 throughout my career as law
enforcement as a Humane officer I
investigated animals associated with
large small and farm
animals then the last 10 years the
growth of neglect towards dogs horses
and farm animals has increased during my
investigation I've learned that the
owners sometimes cannot financially care
for the animals or give the animals
proper care sustenance or
shelter within the last three years has
a Humane officer investigated cases
involving horses living in horrific
conditions farm animals including sheep
goats pigs dying on property and cows
infected with a disease causing them to
be emaciated and die
within the last year I've had a case
involved in goats infected of the herd
due to a chronic crippling disease
CAE and their newborns dehydrated
because their moms could not even walk
or get to drink
water presently I have a seat at the New
Hampshire governance commission
reviewing state laws and ways to educate
police departments and other
agencies house Bel 616 would limit my
ability to investigate and protect
animals that could have consequences
with a negative
outcome instead of Bill 66 616 I urge to
support an alternative solution with a
more effective and fair approach I
respectfully ask that you vote against
the bill 616 and work towards policies
that better serve our community and
Welfare for the animals I appreciate
your time and consideration and would
welcome the opportunity to discuss
anything further please feel free to
contact me at any time okay
thank you for your testimony would you
be willing to take questions okay are
there any questions representative
wheeler thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr McCarthy for taking my question and
for your service how long have you been
with the SPCA I started with the I
retired in
2016 I started with the Pope Memorial
SPCA in stratum I'm sorry in conquered
uh for six and a half years and
transferred over to stratum and I've
been there ever since well thank you
are there any other questions I do have
to add one more thing oh certainly Mr
chair uh as for uh education for us we
have the ability to go further with
education on Animal Welfare called
national animal Control
Association n Academy UNH and other
agencies and online uh training for
animals and so forth okay thank you
uh any other questions seeing none uh
thank you for your testimony thank you
next uh Josie best from Unity New
Hampshire oops don't have my
pillow thank you all of you for
listening um this is very difficult
because I can imagine myself
um and what what would happen if
somebody decided something was wrong
like using a pack bed for the animals
which I do
um Farms are like homes and
houses very rarely are they completely
perfectly picked up clean and neat
except when you know that there's
company
coming because it's an ongoing
process so I can't believe that um Donna
Le's situation was um B really bad and
causing problems but I do understand
when the equipment breaks and you can't
get it fixed um that's as far as you can
go and when you have a Pack the only
time that is really really smelly is
when you're halfway through doing it
because you've opened it up I just want
to explain that cuz that has doesn't
come up I'm one of the people who um
definit helped craft the part about um
the police need need to be trained which
isn't another bill you're looking at but
it's connected to this so I support this
bill
completely I've heard a lot today that's
that's extremely upsetting and I've
heard a lot that uh is totally
contradictory and so it's really hard to
know where the truth is I do know that
if you've ever if you've never heard a
goat scream you've you've really missed
it um it's kind of it's really bad um so
what I all I think I can add today is
I'm really appreciative for all of you
spending some time trying to help us um
solve this problem the reason that I'm
in favor of particularly the police part
of having um jurisdiction but also
having
training is because people have uh as
they talk about stories like this have
said oh how could that poor woman have
let them take the
animals and I said well picture
this Suddenly at your
farm a number of policemen show
up and they have an official paper that
says they can do this
you're not I wouldn't be thinking at all
I I would just be so horrified and so
brokenhearted that um I wouldn't be able
to think and that question did come up
several times so I wanted to answer it
what I think the police being trained
and the police being having to have real
credentials and real papers when they
come is there
because um we don't have a country that
runs with the
gestapo and sometimes that's what some
of this seems like and I know I'm
talking about feelings but there are
feelings
here
um I just can't imagine being in that
situation but as the story
unfolds also can't believe that people
actually were knowledgeable people who
allowed lactating animals
be separated from not only their babies
which were probably getting milk some of
the
time from in natural ways but
also that they would be put taken to a
place where they weren't going to be
milked properly and it did come up once
or twice today that um that didn't
happen and that was part of it sounded
like that was part of why they did
euthanize those animals
that's just uncalled for that that's
just out of line that's just um not
right and so one of the solutions that I
think there is is as long as we have the
chain of command of the police and the
judge with the papers is that those
people do need to be trained and so I
think that that's part of what we were
trying to say is that there are some
wonderful training programs out there
and the we need to have police get that
training so what happens we come to the
solution that we always come to in many
many situations we need to have some
more funds and some more training and
some better nicer thinking for this
there are a whole bunch of things I
could say more on but um there isn't
time and I appreciate your time we need
to pass things in this bill that will
help us prevent
mistakes being made which is the real
cruelty to animals cu the cruelest thing
to animals is to take them away from
where is been home where they have been
getting the right feed and they don't
have to change their feed and change
their care um and that's all I I mean I
could go into a loot lot of other but it
I just hope you all will look at things
and um I'm sad to see that there only
half of the chairs left full yeah it is
getting a bit late um yes so thank you
for your testimony I have a question uh
there is something that is not in this
bill uh there is currently a statute
that says that it is illegal to separate
a
um I think it's the moment it says a
cult from its Dam but it should we're
changing that to F but um that is
specifically for Ean do you think that
should be broadened to other uh
livestock
species if that's what we need to do it
shouldn't need to happen but it
obviously with what has been happening
we do need to explain those things and
the reason is you all know um it used to
be 50 years ago that many people even if
they weren't Farmers themselves they had
some experience with their neighbors and
they knew some of the these things we
have people now people aren't involved
in it they don't know these things and
that's where the training has to come in
yeah okay thank you uh any qu other
questions okay thank you for your
testimony and our Final witness is Eric
sautel of
Lee and and um and you if you have if
there are things that have been
reasonably well covered please
um allude very briefly to them if
necessary thank you Mr chairman my name
is Eric salel I do live in Lee um I
submitted unfortunately it wasn't until
this morning because my computer was
taking on a life of its own but I did
submit um my testimony to all members of
the committee and I hope you have a
chance to read it I guess would Reserve
or wave my testimony and hopefully be
able to be part of the discussion
tomorrow in the work session one thing I
do want to comment on though is is the
chair has just commented about should we
have the same wording for
livestock uh or other livestock that we
have for separating a Colt or a fo from
its Dam um you have to think about the
dairy industry and if they if that that
were the case with the dairy industry
there'd be a big uh decrease in the milk
Market um so you have to be careful
about how you word things of unintended
consequences other than that I would I
would guess um I'd be happy to answer
questions tomorrow if you do have a
chance to read my testimony and with
that I'll conclude thank you does
anybody have any questions right now Mr
chair uh yes M jice representative
wheeler thank you very much Mr chairman
um my question is you submitted it
through the online testimonial portal on
the website no I sent it directly to
each member of the committee okay so
it'll be in our emails it'll be on your
email hopefully thank you Mr Sant
technology is great when it works
abely all right is there uh so um no
other questions thank you thank you very
much for coming in uh is there anyone
else who would like to
speak uh yes um
so U please come up and uh after you're
you you're done then I'll have ask you
to fill out a pink
card is this okay yes uh my name is Dr
Jerry coula I'm a Veterinary and finally
get to meet
you I have submitted a very length the
um testimony online through the portal
so you should have that I came to listen
because I um was not involved in any of
the case but I do have a special
knowledge of the animal cruelty law as
it is written right now and
um I would like you to make sure that
you take a look at the testimony that I
sent in because I covered a lot of
things and all I did was address the law
I did not talk about this particular
case that brought it all about to be
because I don't know the ins and outs of
it so um one of the things I would like
to say is um you you're are aware of the
two ways that you can seize animals in
this state the first one is with a
warrant because the we have the Fourth
Amendment rights for people and animal
are property under the law so nobody can
take them without a warrant okay and
they are also evidence in a cruelty case
now in the warrant there has to be
charges there has to be evidence that
the law has been broken so something in
that list of um essential elements in
the law has to have
triggered the need for a warrant and
that comes with the investigation
okay and the second as you know is the
temporary protective custody which does
have the Clause that a large a
veterinarian licensed in the State uh
has to determine probable cause meaning
that they have to decide that that
animal is in Dire Straits and needs to
be taken out of that
situation in this state um veterinarians
are licensed uh they have to be
graduates of a veterinary school which
has standards all veterinary schools
have the same standards and all
veterinarians are trained in all species
of
animals they need to be licensed they
also need to obtain uh continuing
education to maintain that
license and um there's no requirement
for specialization in the state so that
you're not going to see a special um
citation on somebody's license that
they're only large animal or that
they're cat vets or whatever uh and it's
up to the veterinarians as as the SPCA
has indicated to decide if they feel
they're qualified to get involved with
the cruelty case Okay um one of the
things that was also brought up was the
um indemnity clause at the end of the
law that is in there right now just for
veterinarians that they're absolved from
any criminal or um civil um liability
with their involvement in a cruelty case
um that is there to encourage
veterinarians to participate in animal
cruelty cases and um to to in lie of
making it
mandatory um let me see what else came
up that I thought I could
clarify anyway I've gone through it I'm
not going to testify any longer because
I've just gone through every part of
your law and made comments on the
changes as best I could so I would
appreciate it if you would at least take
a look at that because
um I know that in this
state the
cruelty Law changes are pretty much
reactionary they're going to come about
as a result of a case we don't do things
proactively
like like it would be great to do to sit
there and figure out what's going on
Statewide and make proactive um
recommendations in the law and um some
of the stuff is good some of it is has
unintentional
consequences for the whole field of
animal cruelty investigation so I just
like to that's it for now I'll take
questions so I have a question uh which
which is um the the uh protective St uh
custody statute uh that I um I've been
told that that is only applicable if the
owner is not present is that clear from
the way the statute is written no it is
not clear and there are situations
when um it might be used when the owner
is present okay and what would those
situations be those situations would be
if there was a complaint
and an investigating officer which at
this time could be a police officer an
animal control officer or an officer of
a licensed Humane Society goes to
investigate that complaint and they see
an animal that is in dire shape and the
owner's there and refuses to give it up
they can still um take that animal if if
they feel that it's exigent
circumstances sometimes that may be in a
household with more than one animal and
it might be only one that they're not
caring for but there remember that the
cruelty law is there to protect the
animals it's it's not to protect the
people they have their own laws um and
it is there the language or the
Essential Elements of the law or what
constitutes animal cruelty is what our
society has decided this is no way to
keep an animal so New Hampshire citizens
have basically drafted this law with
a knowing what's proper and right for
the care of animals so
um it's unusual to have an owner there
that
uh would deny care an example and I've
actually seen this myself
um dogs and hot cars police will come
out
they'll get the owner back they'll get
the animal out of the
car and they usually suggest that that
owner take the animal to the
veterinarian because this can be very
critical they can die very quickly they
can die after they' come out of the car
and sometimes an owner will refuse it's
my dog I'll do what I want to do with it
the police officer can then take that
animal directly to the veterinarian and
do what needs to be done and
then deal with the owner afterwards and
that that would be under the protective
uh custody statute
yeah is the do you believe the statute
Ed is as it is currently written makes
that very
clear I've I've always assumed that it
could be um it does not say anything
about owner being present so I would
assume that it's a a lot of cases are
when the owner is not present it's a
abandonment um people sometimes the
owner has actually passed away in the
household or the owner's on vacation and
the person was supposed to be taken care
of them isn't it's there's a lot of
different situations where that could
come into play and obviously we can't
sit here and think of all of them but to
limit it to when the owner is not
present might be hamstringing certain
cases that come about right okay so I
guess my qu the the intent of my
question is that do we need to uh
address any lack of clarity in that stat
you could say whether the owner is
present or not in fact I put that in my
statement an option thank you are there
other
questions okay thank you very
much and uh if you could fill out the
pink card and bring it up to the clerk
uh okay are is there anyone else would
who would like to
testify all right well with that I'll
close the hearing on a have oh yes yes
could we get the thank you for the
reminder um if someone could bring up
the blue sheet and what do we have for
numbers online um I think I think um I
don't know how to speaker oh yeah I
don't know how to look at those but I do
you do as well okay okay yes pleas
okay so uh on the blue sheet we have one
two three four five uh in favor and one
one
opposed and then online we
have uh 16 in favor and 166
opposed thank you very much thank you
very thank
you and with that we'll close the
hearing on HB
616 for
okay to our committee
members we will see you
tomorrow at 9:30
we will have a committee work session on
this bill that we just
heard and then we have uh four hearing
scheduled for
tomorrow so have a good rest of the
evening travel safe and thank you for
all your
work e